Hello Ladies and gentlemen and everybody else.
It's up.
Fuckers.
This episode is brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a a pretty awesome service and what it is is a website,
essentially a self help website that allows you to do a lot of the things that
you would ordinarily have to go to an attorney's office to handle.
You can do it yourself online.
They will divvy,
they were developed by top attorneys to provide self help services at your
specific direction.
It's not a legal firm,
it's not a law firm,
but they provide you with legal self help and they can also provide you with a
contact for a third party independent attorney if the shit hits the fan.
And what does this mean?
It means that like if you want to form an LLC,
if you want to incorporate,
if you want to get a will,
a power of attorney living trust,
things along those lines,
you can do all that step by step on legal zoom.
And it's very easy to do.
I know a lot of people who have done that on it was formed that way.
Uh,
Brian formed his desk squad company.
That way,
all that is done through legal zoom.
Super easy to do.
There's a lot of things that you would ordinarily have to go to a lawyer.
You'd have to put your clothes on,
you'd have to make an appointment.
You could be naked drunk at home and do legal stuff.
It's amazing,
amazing and not very expensive.
Uh,
you can form an LLC from 99 bucks.
they've been helping Americans get personal wills,
power of attorney,
doing all that stuff for over 10 years,
and they have an a plus from the better business bureau,
which to me is giant.
You know,
they don't just give those away.
So I liked that.
I know people that have used this service.
I liked that my friends have used this service and I liked that.
I just hear nothing but good things about them.
You can even get a divorce if you know the other person you're going to get
divorce with is really cool.
But if they're not,
and then if they're really that cool,
why are you divorcing him the fuck you doing?
I wonder how many people have gotten divorced through legal zoom.
It's probably be like three.
I might be wrong,
but you could do it.
Um,
so go there,
go to legalzoom.com.
Enter the Codeword Rogan in the referral box at checkout and you can save some
money that way.
Protect your family,
protect your future.
All of it at legal zoom,
legal help.
Furnish through vetted independent attorneys.
It's a sweet fucking website.
I really enjoyed legal zoom.
I liked the fact that there's a lot of things that you know you used to be super
inconvenient to deal with,
like simple legal issues like forming a corporation.
You can do all of that now.
You can start your own business now@legalzoom.com and when you do that,
go to the checkout box in the referral box at checkout rather,
and entering the codeword Rogan for more savings.
So that's legalzoom.com and enter the code word Rogan were also brought to you
by nature box.
I got a new batch of naturebox,
Jamie.
Oh,
you're going to love all this new
groovy shit we got.
But no Sriracha.
Cashews.
I've fucking talk too much about Serratia cashews and now you bitches all buy
them up.
They know Sriracha cashews left.
We're fucking killing the cashew farmers.
There was poor cashew farmers and those Porsche Rochan makers,
their work a double,
triple overtime sweating their balls off trying to make serratia cashews.
But there's,
what's that?
Yeah,
we all need some blueberry Ahmond's though.
Dark cocoa almonds.
If you had those.
Oh good lord and peanut butter,
nom noms.
They might be my new favorite.
Peter.
Pardon?
Num noms might take the place of Serratia cashews but I shouldn't tell you
fuckers cause then you buy them all up to,
uh,
what naturebox is,
is you order it online and you pick the stuff that you want and then they send
you boxes every week and here's the deal behind it.
If you are a person that works in an office and you have one of those goddamn
vending machines attempts you,
you kind of hungry and you walk by and like the most healthy thing in there,
it's like some shitty as Granola bar and you know,
that's not what you want to eat.
And he definitely don't want to eat candy,
but you wind up doing it just because you're hungry.
Naturebox gives you hundreds and I mean hundreds of delicious snacks to choose
from.
Really good stuff and there's a lot of stuff that you don't have to feel guilty
about.
There's a few things that are a bit questionable if you'd pretzels and things
along those lines are not necessarily good for you,
but they have zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup,
all that stuff that's really shitty for your body,
low in sugar.
You can get plenty of them that are low in sugar and non GMO and without gluten
and they shipped for free.
Um,
peanut butter nom nom is,
like I said,
are my favorites,
but there's so many good ones.
The blueberry Ahmond's or to live in the big apple pie,
big island,
pineapples are fantastic.
There's a lot of really healthy choices that you could choose from that are
delicious.
They're really good.
I've signed up a bunch of friends on naturebox.com and you know,
they,
no one's complaining.
Everybody's enjoying the shit out of it.
Brian's completely addicted to it.
That fucker doesn't even go food shopping anymore.
He just buys naturebox.
It hasn't stacked around a second house.
It needs to go to a God damn grocery store.
He wonders why he's not feeling good all the time.
Fucking dude's smoking cigarettes and eating snacks like a God damn meal.
But in between meals,
naturebox is seriously the way to go.
It's the official snack provider for a the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
We have them laying around the office right now.
It just brought in a brand new box,
and if you go to naturebox.com right now,
you'll get 50% off your first months first box.
So go to naturebox.com/rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan for 50% off your months.
First box,
try it out.
No more hungry and it's no more crankiness and no more shitty choices from those
goddamn vending machines.
Really Yummy food that's,
you know,
packaged in a very convenient,
easy way.
It's delicious and it's about as good a choice as you can get when it comes to
snack foods.
So naturebox.com forward slash Rogen go there and enjoy some delicious savings.
And last but not least,
we're brought to you by [inaudible] Dot Com that is o.N n.
I.
T.
We are a human optimization website.
And on it we sell all of the very best in strength and conditioning equipment
and supplements,
athletic supplements,
supplements that are designed to help you improve your performance,
both in cognitive function,
uh,
your physical fitness performance,
your endurance.
We have,
uh,
things that aid in recovery.
We just find one of the best shit that we can find online,
whether it's a athletic equipment,
like a battle ropes or kettle bells or things along those lines,
medicine balls,
all things that provide what we call functional strength and what functional
strength is the IB.
The idea behind functional strength is athletic equipment and exercises that
improve performance in any given task.
Like,
um,
like if you do bicep curls,
it's not necessarily going to help you do Jujitsu or it's not going to
necessarily help you throw punches better.
It's gonna make your arms look bigger,
you little fucking sexy at the beach and shit.
But the reality of athletic performance is your body has to move as one
individual unit,
all parts moving together to enhance your w,
your athletic performance,
not just your ability to lift weights in a very specific and isolated way.
And uh,
that's what kettle bells are all about.
I'm a huge fan of kettlebells.
If you've heard this podcast before,
you'd probably like,
we shut the fuck up about Kettlebells,
Jesus Christ son.
But I just think that these a bad fucking Russians,
they figured out some cool shit.
Um,
and they figured out a long time ago,
one of the best ways to improve athletic performance is this thing called the
kettle bell.
It's like a bowling ball,
an iron bowling ball with a handle on the top of it.
And it's all about swinging these things around and it's all about overcoming a
nurse Hsa and using your whole body and these explosive movements.
And it is just absolutely fantastic for developing full body strength,
like full body strength where you can just move couches easier.
You know,
if you're doing any sort of a sport,
whether it's tennis or you know,
anything,
you will have more physical strength to draw upon.
Um,
and uh,
we sell the very best ones that we can find,
including the primal bells and the Zombie Bells,
which are two,
a artistic kettle bells that we had designed.
Um,
we had a,
the primal bells designed to the great apes.
It's a chimpanzees how we are monkeys,
Orangutans and gorillas,
uh,
all various weights from 18 pounds up to 72 pounds and uh,
they're all three d balanced as well.
Um,
you,
there's some artistic kettle bells that are out there,
uh,
from other companies and they look really cool.
But the reality is you want a kettle bell to be completely symmetrically
balanced so that when you're swinging it,
there's not like some weird momentum that comes from the,
the odd shape of it.
We designed these kettlebells to make sure that not only do they look great,
but they function the exact same way as regular kettle bells.
So either prepare for the gorilla,
take over or the Zombie apocalypse with primal bells or Zombie bells.
And then get your freak on at [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n I t,
use the Codeword Rogan and you will save 10% off any and all supplements.
All right.
That's it.
And of commercials.
Robin motherfucker blockers,
acutely music,
young Jamie landscape,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast by night.
There's very few people in this life can say that they've gone from Glam rock to
expert MMA commentary and even fighting in MMA.
Very few people other than you,
Robin black.
There might be some lady out there,
so check that out out.
Yeah,
it's pretty weird.
I,
I tend to try to do stuff that I like.
That's kind of my goal in life.
Just do a bunch of stuff.
I like.
That's a beautiful goal,
man.
And if everybody did that,
we would have a lot more happy people in this world.
Yeah,
right,
right.
Yeah.
You do a fantastic job.
You work for the fight network in Canada,
right?
Yeah.
And you do a fantastic job of breaking down fights and your enthusiasm is so
contagious.
It's really cool.
It's really enjoyed watching those videos because as a person myself who's a
huge fan of fights and just just,
there's so many aspects that I think that maybe the casual fan might miss or the
person who was never trained or competed my miss and you do a great job of sort
of encapsulating those really important moments and and and highlighting them
and isolating them and you do it all with passion.
It's really fun
man.
Thank you.
That is the coolest thing anyone's ever said to me.
Like I just,
I really fucking love doing these things.
Like you could tell.
Yeah,
I do like to spend hours sitting there and look at how beautifully these guys
moves in the moment in time where too unwilling guys are like,
they each are trying to choreograph their own thing and what's going on
psychically and what's going on mentally like it.
Honest to God,
I've done a lot of fun things and they all seem to kind of lead to this.
And if I could only do one thing for the rest of my life,
I'd spend my time in my little lab researching what's going on when two men
fight.
Like that's what I do with my life and that's what I do now.
And I absolutely love doing it.
Yeah,
you could tell and I'm like I said,
as someone like me who is also a huge fan of MMA and a huge,
uh,
a huge fan of watching two people trying to figure each other out in the most
dangerous and most,
uh,
the most high stake sport I think in the world,
maybe not the most dangerous as far as like,
I mean,
I guess like maybe Nascar is probably more dangerous,
dangerous,
but the high stakes of the human hand to hand combat,
to me,
there's so much on the line,
there's so much psychologically going on and there's so many little things.
Like I'm sure there's a lot that I'm missing if I watch basketball.
I'm sure there's a lot that I'm missing.
If you watch football,
but when it comes to striking and grappling and mixed martial arts,
the variables are so,
and the different approaches to overcoming those variables is so gigantic.
Like you did a recent thing on Gunnar Nelson and a gunner Nelson who is a
Jujitsu expert and now an MMA fighter out of Iceland.
Yeah.
Who's a really interesting dude.
Like super stoic.
Yeah.
Fucking cold as ice.
Never smiles.
Never laughs.
He's,
he's a weird dude,
but wicked Jujitsu.
I remember him from the,
just before he ever got into MMA or high level MMA.
Um,
he beat my fucking Monton.
Yeah.
Cool.
Real love.
I remember seeing this little guy on monsoons back.
I'm like,
who is that motherfucker?
Like that guy is a beast.
How do you take Jeff Monsoons back?
Yeah.
And it's,
it,
that calmness.
He uses that so intelligently.
Like I was,
I'm reading this will,
have you heard of this book?
The rise of Superman?
No.
Oh Dude,
look to read this book immediately.
So this guy goes and he has researched the biochemistry that's happening in the
brain at the opera,
at the moments where people feel like a surfer feels like at one with the wave,
you know where I free climb or feels at one with the wall,
there's actually biochemistry happening in the brain and there's four for a
neurotransmitters that are released simultaneously.
And in that moment there's all of these things that humans do better.
Uh,
one of them is pattern recognition.
So when two guys are fighting,
you can see patterns in how they move and predict outcomes,
right?
And got a different guys get into it in different ways.
The bulk of the research is on action and sports,
like flipping motorcycles through the air five times and stuff.
Cause those guys,
if they are not in that state,
they die,
right?
So the level now,
like there's exponential growth in what people can now do in that state because
it's being sort of a global experiment that men are pushing each other further
and further.
I mean,
everybody used to gather around to see,
um,
uh,
evil.
Knievel jumped 10 buses.
Now everyday 10 guys do that and flipped four times while doing it,
you know?
So the level of what people are able to mentally accomplish.
So that's happening in fighting and the thing,
and I'm obsessed with science so that what's going on physically is fascinating
what's going on psychologically,
but the science has crazy and that's kind of where my research is going now.
Like if you could take an EEG and put it on their brain in the highest moments
of combat,
what's going on in,
I wonder if you ever could do that because if they were in that highest one
would combat and they had an EEG on their brain,
would they be thinking the same?
Because what they realize they had an EEG and what did distract them?
In
theory,
if all these people screaming and you sit in at the side of the cage and wearing
your underpants getting punched in the face,
if all that isn't distracting,
a couple of things on your head.
It's hard to say though.
I mean the state,
what you want,
what you want to check with that EEG or something is the mental state of the
biochemistry,
the neurology happening in the brain.
And if they're not in that state,
you can't do it.
But people have done it in other,
they've done it and looked at what's happening in the brain and there's
something called dumb,
a hypo frontal ism.
We're actually less as happening in the front of your brain during these moments
of like perfect performance.
And that's what this book's about.
This guy is like,
like chemically analyzing the highest level of performance.
So to take that into fighting,
these guys are operating at that level now.
Like the top guys,
Carlos Condit is operating at that level.
You know,
he's operating in moments of pure flow and when these guys are in those moments,
what's happening in that?
That's shit's fascinating.
Like to look at fights and under and look and see that these guys are operating
at the highest level of human performance and in that state against each other,
they're fighting each other.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
it's really fascinating.
Um,
the book is called the rise of Superman and it's by a guy named Steven Kotler
and uh,
it's got four and a half stars on amazon.com.
So that's a,
that's a pretty,
it's a great book.
I'm going to do a little breakdown on what's going on with pattern recognition
in that state.
And imagine you and I are both in that state and you know that I'm starting to
recognize patterns.
You can lay traps for me by doing something called chunking where you'll go one,
two,
three,
four and all start to recognize that pattern and anticipate it and you'll change
one thing.
That pattern in hidden,
right?
So chunking,
use,
understanding that I'm predicting your patterns and using that against me,
like all of that kind of stuff just fascinates the shit out of me.
Right.
Well that's always been a big thing about striking,
about changing up the speed of your approach and also throwing faints in
pretending to go one way and going another.
There's all sorts of different things that people have done to try to offset
pattern rec
mission and each other's brains like your,
your brain.
The better your brain performs,
the different I have to approach to make you pay for having such a good
performing brain.
You know what I mean?
Like your brain can anticipate stuff.
So I need to make you make that a bad thing for you.
Wow.
You know,
so it's what it says here at Fau.
That flow is caused by a mighty cocktail,
five powerful chemicals from dopamine,
serotonin.
And that's interesting that I've never really thought about it,
that,
that the have all these chemicals flowing together.
I've always thought of it as just sort of a quote unquote state of mind that you
achieve a state of mind.
But this state of mind being a bunch of neural transmitters are flowing together
and the optimum level.
Yeah,
man.
Like think of that.
The way,
uh,
like this,
your state of mind affects your emotion and your emotion affects your
biochemistry and your biochemistry affects your performance.
So it's,
they're linked to each other.
So that idea that guys get focused,
that focus causes a biochemical change and the brand,
this is the kind of Shit I want to go to next on my breakdowns.
And they start playing with this kind of stuff and evolutionary things.
You've probably read that the hand part of the reason that evolved the way it
did was for fighting.
We read that in the jaw and stuff exactly like so start looking at what that
means and why they're like the science of that kind of stuff is just starting to
my mind.
It is totally fascinating stuff and it's also the,
the thing about this achieving this flow state that's so maddening for people is
that it's,
it just slips through your fingers.
It's there and it's gone.
It's you achieve these brief moments where you've seen it in basketball games
where a guy just feels like you can't mass.
He hits those three partners from the outside in pool.
I played pool a lot in you've,
there's these moments,
they're rare and fleeting,
but when they come it's like you can't miss it.
You know where everything is,
be willing to bat.
You're in that state some huge percentage of time when you're doing comedy
because once you read about it,
there's a whole bunch of confidence that how it affects your way,
your inhibitions,
and your unwillingness to to use inhibitions.
You're probably in that state almost always when you're hitting it in comedy.
Yeah,
I would think so.
Because when you're doing comedy,
I've always described it as you're more like a passenger,
right?
Then you are like the pilot.
You were all just,
you just kind of like doing it and like sometimes words will come out of your
mouth and you're like,
I don't even know if I could take credit for those words because I guess it's
not,
I know it's me.
It's coming out of my mouth.
I know it's my voice.
I know.
Technically I created them,
I wrote them,
but it's not really me that's doing it.
It's like it's just coming out on its own
and,
and a guy who catches an enormous killer wave will say exactly the same thing.
And a guy who walks a tight rope over top of Niagara Falls will say the same
thing.
You're going into that state in that time.
Yeah,
I would imagine.
And in Jujitsu you see it as well,
like when guys are rolling,
there's moments where you know like there's a certain transition,
like someone will hit the over under,
the guy will try to escape a flow immediately to an arm bar and then immediately
to a triangle and it's all happening so fast.
It's almost impossible for that person to be thinking.
They're just reacting and hitting those moves and just completely like in that
zone.
One of the aspects of flow state is that Eh,
you,
you interpret time differently.
So you'll hear that from a lot of fighters.
I mean one of the things I think that helps me analyze stuff is that when I
fought,
I had success in a terrible failures,
like terrible embarrassing.
Changing who you are as a man.
Failures.
How many times,
you know,
nine.
Yeah.
And the one for them,
I'm,
I'm going to do one last fight.
I'm going to end five wins at 45 five wins and five losses.
You're sure?
I'm sure.
Hey Man,
I have to get to 10.
I mean,
but I'm telling you,
I had the kind of losses that make you question who you are as a man.
You know what I mean?
For four days or weeks or affect your pop into your head experiencing that.
I think that's an analyst's life.
Like I've had a flow state.
My last fight I won in the second round.
I literally completely did whatever I wanted for seven minutes.
It was perfect.
And two fights earlier,
my brain almost melted down.
When I look back,
I don't know if I lost vision or if I fainted or what,
like just absolute utter failure and it,
and it hurts you because in our genes,
the,
when males would fight,
if one of them would lose,
you'd be kicked out of the,
out of the,
uh,
the group.
Like you may never have sex again.
You may never a one loss of a fight with another male could change your history
for the rest of your life.
That's in our genes only x generations ago.
And we still feel that.
But failure is really fucking brutal.
But it makes you look at these things differently.
Like now when I look at these elite level fighters who can do that every day,
every day,
I've such a marvel and what they're capable of and I think that's cause I got
brutally embarrassed and fight before you know and I think and you'd sure don't
like that experience but you,
it changes who you are and hopefully in good ways later on.
Well it also when you lose and whenever you fail at something and you feel that
awful feeling of failure,
the motivation that comes from that to never feel that again is almost
impossible to recreate without having experienced failure.
You find it in comedy,
I experienced it and fighting as well,
but that those moments where when it's over,
you just feel like such a hunk of shit that like when you're training from then
on you,
your intensity is so much higher because the stakes are higher because you know
that there's a brutal beat down by somebody is such a horrible proposition.
Not just in the moment but after that moment.
The,
the thinking about the act of thinking about it the same as failing.
Like,
I think failure as a person and especially as a man,
I think it's a huge part of life.
I think it's an important part of life and it's the people that stay on the
couch and don't risk anything.
The Uri that's trying to stay comfortable is one of the worst decisions you
could ever make as a man.
Trying to stay comfortable as a terrible,
terrible path.
Yeah,
because you're just going to stay soft and weak and you're never going to figure
out anything.
He never gonna accomplish shit.
I,
I've got to do some pretty fun things.
I have a really good life.
I like everything that I do and a,
I got to kill her wife and I live in Canada.
I have fun and stuff and I really think the only two things that I ever had
going for me was that I have a crazy good work ethic and I'm not afraid to look
like an idiot.
I don't give a fuck.
I am not afraid to look like an idiot.
Failure sucks and it hurts you but thee be not afraid to be made fun of or,
or put down or looked at and laughed at and not give a shit about that.
You'll try stuff,
you know,
you'll go for things like you'll do stuff and uh,
I mean,
man,
nobody ever had more haters than a guy who are eye make up and tried to go into
the fight game.
Like,
I mean,
fucking everybody hated me.
Everybody in Canada,
like anybody in the fight business and here I am fucking six years later,
all you can do is put your head down and try to do good work.
You can't do anything else.
Nothing.
He can't kiss anybody's ass.
I was talking to Eddie about this too.
You can't kiss anybody's ass.
You can't beg your way out of it.
You can't buy way out of it.
If they hate
you and they think you're a joke,
the only answer is to just do,
try to do great work.
There's no other,
there's no other care.
And uh,
that's what I tried to do.
Yeah.
I think in that sense,
sometimes it's good to have haters because it keeps you motivated,
it keeps you motivated.
And it also,
it's,
it's a balancing act,
you know,
I think,
I think the world needs Yin and Yang.
The world needs push and pull.
And I think that having some negativity in your life,
it makes the positivity feels so much better.
Yeah.
No,
it makes it,
it makes a lot of sense,
man.
We,
I mean,
we were just talking about losing what,
you know,
if there's is that evolutionary reason and that like deep ns at all.
My God,
I am never,
I'm going to be made,
pushed out of the group and never have sex again.
I'm going to wander the earth alone for the rest of my life that's in us.
But I think also,
uh,
you know,
I forgot where I was going.
He's not even stolen.
Yeah,
no,
I had an edible this morning.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean it's just one of those things.
It's a miserable,
miserable thing,
but I know where I was going.
Winning is so good because losing so terrible,
you know,
like,
I mean,
if losing didn't suck,
winning would be,
oh cool,
let's go try and win again next weekend.
I remember when I was competing the day of the competition,
there was always moments where I was like,
I gotta stop doing this.
Like,
this is just too much stress.
It just feels terrible.
This is,
and then once I would,
when I would go,
this is the greatest feeling in the world has ever known.
Like people who I feel sorry for people who don't know what this feels like to
just to,
to win like a major taekwondo tournament or something like that.
It was just the craziest feeling.
Like you just felt like,
wow,
all that work paid off and that fuels you as a person to accomplish other
things.
It gives you this,
this understanding of focus and of motivation and discipline and that if you
apply all those things to anything,
to writing,
to whatever you trying to do,
to building a business to whatever you're trying to do,
you can accomplish things that you felt were insurmountable before.
For sure.
I mean,
uh,
there was,
the opposite of that too is in us,
I think we all think if the Zombie apocalypse happens tomorrow,
I'll be the guy rolls the car off,
my wife picks her up,
runs out of here,
kills 10 zombies on the way,
gets on the helicopter and gets out of there.
But that's not entirely always true.
And you need to find that out about yourself,
right?
You need to,
yeah.
You need to face the fire.
Don't understand what it's like to be under extreme pressure.
Yeah.
And uh,
and losing makes you say,
I'm not necessarily that guy who fucking flips the car.
Does that jumps,
kills 10 zombies.
But then if you can come back and when you go,
you know what,
if I'm at my best,
if I'm focused,
if I have,
I have my shit together some of the time I can be that guy.
And I think that's what you kind of hope for.
Well,
it's also objective analysis of your own shortcomings and your own strengths.
And that comes in martial arts.
It's a huge factor in martial arts because when,
especially when you're training,
when you're in the gym and you're sparring with,
you know,
if you got a great gem,
like you're training a 10th planet Jiu Jitsu or something like that,
you got just a whole room full of killers and everyone kind of knows the food
chain.
Everyone knows where everybody stands and why does everyone know where everybody
stands?
We know where everybody stands because we're tapping each other out on a regular
basis.
And so because of that you're forced to really analyze your game.
Like this motherfucker gets me in his guard,
I'm in trouble.
Like I got a status guys,
guard,
I know this.
Why?
Because I've been caught.
I understand it.
Whereas if you don't have any experience overcoming adversity,
like nobody's catching me.
And then you get in there with somebody who just rag dolls you and you like what
the fuck?
And like your ideas of who you are a change because you,
you have this distorted.
But like how many guys out there that have never fought have this crazy
distorted perception of what they're capable,
insane.
Like nobody looks at Tiger Woods and goes on the right damn that guy,
1818 holes.
You don't know how I play golf.
I played golf.
I would dominate because I'm taking it to the street and it's going to be
fucking street golf.
You know like guys really think that,
but that's a lack of understanding of what that really is.
I mean you can kind of see it that the willingness or the ability to go,
there's trouble,
I'm going to hit it with this fist that's in every guy.
So they don't understand that other guys have an understanding of physics and
understanding of where the body works.
What happens when you hit somebody in the throat?
What that the natural instinct to roll away gives them your back.
Like all the most basics.
They don't even understand that exists.
Right?
So they have the idea that if I hit that thing with this thing,
I might be able to beat it.
That somehow or another they're tougher.
Somehow they're more alpha,
other whatever,
whatever goofy shit they have in their head.
And it's just a prop.
It's like,
it's like a building that they use for a movie,
but there's nothing inside the house.
Like you have this like this fake facade and then behind there there's no house.
Where's your fucking house?
Ah,
you know,
and some fucking beast mounts you and start to pound that on you and you give
your back and you're like,
and then after that's over,
you're so devastated and defeated and who you,
your perceptions of who you are.
We're so screwy.
Yeah.
I can't tell you how many times I've had guys tell me that they would never lose
if they fought because my mentality,
they're always like this job,
bro.
I don't move my mentality.
That's,
I've had a dozen.
Why do they all have a tie in accent?
They're all Italian.
It's a huge part of my,
uh,
my culture.
The Italians,
I don't know what it is about my people,
but they're goofy as fuck when it comes to that.
They have this bizarre belief in their ability to fight.
That's awesome.
I don't know what it is.
It's that long.
Most of the time,
you know,
even if it's wrong,
like you see dudes do terrible things,
treat people bad,
knee assholes.
If that guy took a beating when he was 15 he'd be a better person.
You're right.
He will be a way better guide today.
He would treat people better,
he'd under it,
but you know,
there's not enough of that going on.
We're really soft.
Like our culture is really so like buy a fight network where I work,
there's like a metro where though you get groceries and then we used to walk
around this building,
it takes like four minutes and they built this path on the other side so it only
takes two minutes now costs like 80 a hundred thousand to strip it out,
put the stuff down and put,
what the fuck are we doing that for?
When you're in Canada,
that will part of Canada,
Toronto,
it's cold as fuck for about two minutes.
I mean it's like we're going to literally spend money to make sure that people
don't have to go do more effort for two minutes.
Even escalators,
like,
why don't we make this shit like,
you know what I mean?
We in the history of humankind,
there has never been a softer culture than North America,
Canada.
You got never in human history.
You know,
and that's,
I think another reason why fighting is so interesting because in a world like
that,
let's go see what happens when we see the opposite of that.
When we see people who drive it to the hardest level,
push it as far as it can humanly go and go in and gets another guy.
You're talking about a guy saying,
oh,
you know,
I'm hard.
That guy's fucking hard to,
right.
The guy you're fighting is also mentally unbelievably talented.
He's also,
and he's better than you.
Yeah.
And he's training every day,
check active,
and he's got a real balanced sense of who he is.
He's a real martial artist.
Yeah.
That,
that's a good point.
That how soft we are is one of the reasons why it's so exciting to see someone
compete in such a,
it's such a dangerous and volatile profession,
but the critics of MMA would say,
well,
the reason why we are so quote unquote soft is that our race or the human race
is evolving and that we are moving towards a state where we no longer require
physical conflict.
I think that martial arts is the key to that gap in the deal,
and this is,
it would seem like contradictory to someone who doesn't engage in martial arts,
but I think that the realities of the biology,
the realities of the body itself and the long history of combat,
that it's ingrained in our genetics.
Our DNA has this long history of all these people before us that had to fight to
stay alive,
whether it's to fight off animals or fight off intruders or photo and this.
All this conflict is almost built into the system.
And one of the best ways,
in my opinion,
to ensure peace is to actually exercise out all of that conflict in the gym so
that it doesn't exist in society.
It doesn't exist in the workplace and it doesn't exist in friendships and it
doesn't exist in,
in,
you know,
in the,
the world at large,
it only exists in doe Joe's.
It only exists in gyms.
And some of the nicest,
most respectful people I have ever met have been killers,
murderers,
I mean in the gym,
you know,
in,
in the,
in the cage,
in,
in boxing rings.
Kickboxers the nicest folks because of the fact that they,
they have no insecurities when it comes to that stuff.
They,
their co,
their focus when it comes to their martial arts is not about,
you know,
like it's not about going out and bullying people on the street or going out
picking fights.
No,
their focus is in bettering their skills and in doing so and in training really
hard,
all your need to prove all that goes away.
Like some I've seen like MMA fighters that people don't know and they get into
discussions with people when someone will get douchey with them and they'll
smile and laugh.
Like there's a famous story,
my friend Tate Fletcher fought on the ultimate fighter.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu is a bad motherfucker.
It's cool ass dude too.
Super Nice.
If you're a friendly guy,
Tate's going to be your best friend.
He's just the nicest guy ever.
But we were in the hard rock hotel and there was this big fucking kid,
man.
He was like six foot six,
maybe at least six,
four,
six,
five and Tate's like six,
four.
So this guy was bigger than tape and uh,
like probably like a big,
he's probably like college age 23,
24.
And he was just being a fucking trunk asshole to everybody and just walking
around with his shirt off this big giant kid.
And he got to Tate's door and he said to Tate like,
hey man,
that's my fucking room.
And a Tate's like,
no,
I'm pretty sure it's my room.
He's like,
I got my key right here and I'm gonna use the key and a cake take goes,
take it easy.
And t Tate opens his door and goes inside.
And I had the room next to Tate.
So I go inside my room and I hear bang,
Bang,
Bang.
I hear banging on tates door and we had our doors open.
You know,
we uh,
yeah,
the adjoining rooms and I stepped through tastes target.
What the fuck's going on?
Is that,
that same guy.
And so Tate opens a guy,
he goes,
don't you shut the door on me bitch?
Like it was like some crazy moment where this guy was like,
not just picking a fight,
but going after Tate.
Once he went into the room,
they go out to the hallway and people do that.
And it's just so big.
Bullying,
just a big bully who'd used to be,
you know,
used to being a big bully.
And,
um,
take goes,
uh,
what do you,
you know,
what do you want to do man?
What do you want to do?
He goes,
he goes,
I'm gonna kick your fucking ass.
Let's take those.
Once you come over here and swing on me,
man,
come on,
come on.
So a Tate is standing in front of the dude and the dude's to,
and the dude is like,
oh shit,
this is really happening.
And then Tate throws an inside leg kick and then pulls,
guard grabs the guy pulls guard before the guy even knows it,
Tate hooks and Alma Plata is on the side of the guy and then security shows up.
So he's got this guy in normal plot that he's got his arm under his neck and the
normal Plata and security shows up and they go,
stop,
stop.
So I go,
don't worry about it man.
I go,
it's fine.
He's just going to put them to sleep.
It's okay.
And the and the security guy goes,
hey,
you're that guy from fear factor.
And in that moment,
in that moment with the security guys are completely going,
Holy Shit,
what are you doing here man?
I go,
this drunk guys picking on my friend.
And when,
when I said like,
don't worry,
he's just going to put them to sleep.
Tate said that in his head.
He was like,
all right,
I guess I wouldn't put them asleep now.
He wasn't going to hit the guy.
He just decided like,
look,
if I hit this guy and then it becomes crazy salt and there's marks on him.
So Tate just chokes it,
puts a rear naked,
choke on him and sleep some right there in the hallway.
His friends picked the guy up and it's like a scene in that goddamn movie.
His friends picked the guy up,
they put him in the hotel,
the elevator,
the elevator door closes and the guy at vanishes and he disappears from line.
That is labs all night.
We for years,
we still bring this up.
This shit happened to like 2003 we still bring this up because it was so
ridiculous.
Uh,
you've seen Ryan,
what's his name?
That Ju Jitsu guy in a bar and he takes the guy down.
Takes his bat or a mountain.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Tom Hall,
right?
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
Gets him down mount some waits till he's exhausted.
Yeah.
Well he's used to doing that all the time.
That's the thing about training is like you're used to struggling like
essentially for your life.
What does it tap?
Tap is a way that you can train where it's safe and someone taps and what that
means is,
you know you got me,
but what?
What has got me means it means you're dead.
I would have died or my arm would have broken in half and then he killed.
Then you kill them.
It's essentially you're playing a game called I kill you with my body or you
kill me or we kill each other several times over the course of a seven minute
rolling session and then we shake hands.
Thanks man,
that was great.
And then you move on to the next day.
I walked out of there.
Well it'd be a better person and I agree 100% it exercises that stuff out of
your system.
That's the frustrating thing when all of a sudden,
you know,
I come to town and my wife's here and her friends are like,
what's the deal with this war machine?
And Christy Mack,
they don't know about any of this stuff.
They don't know about in any of the good things about,
about martial arts.
They don't know about any of the good things it does.
It makes people a better person.
They just come in and they're like,
hey,
some submit MMA fighter beat up a porn star.
Like,
you know what I mean?
They don't know.
Like they don't know that there's that side to it that Marshall had to make sure
better fucked up story.
I don't,
you know,
I don't know what exactly went down.
Like people keep asking me to comment on it.
This is the only thing I would ever say any anytime,
you know,
there's an altercation like that between a man and a woman and a man hits a
woman,
it's,
it's never correct.
It's always evil.
It's always wrong.
It's beyond fucked that a guy could beat a woman.
It's beyond fuck.
And it should be,
it should be a heinous crime that's punishable in,
in the worst ways possible.
But I don't know what happened.
You know,
all I know is it appears according to her story that he beat the shit out of
her.
That's what it looks like.
There's no evidence to the contrary.
And that's awful.
So that's all I could say.
I mean,
I'm not commenting on it until,
I mean really commenting on until I know more of what exactly happened.
I don't know what the fuck went down,
but I don't know how it got,
could do that.
I literally do not know how a man,
especially a martial artist,
he always likes to think of yourself as not a martial artist.
He's a fighter,
you know?
Yeah.
And that's probably true.
He's an animal,
you know.
And there are
those guys typically in the gym,
you don't get guys get that good that are animals like that.
They don't have enough,
they have too much ego to go,
I'm not good at this,
so I have to train that to get better.
So you don't,
these guys come into,
you know,
a big gym and they're new and they're tough guys.
They're gone in a year.
They don't have,
they won't have the,
the absence of ego enough to train and things are not good at.
And then they ended up leaving.
So it's rare that somebody has to be very driven of like a,
you know,
a,
an animal style fighter typed,
get past that to get to that level or just be genetically really superior,
you know,
or whatever.
It's rare that that style of person becomes a high level.
I'm a
fun.
Yeah,
it is.
It is rare because if you're that fucked in the head,
usually not strong enough mentally to keep going and to get to that salmon war
machines.
Uh,
he's a high level MMA fighter.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean it's,
it's just so disappointing.
I had them in the podcast was six months ago maybe.
Something like that.
Yeah.
It's a weird,
unbelievably sad that like you said,
we don't really know.
Life's over.
Yeah.
I'll fucking,
life is over.
I mean,
I dunno what he's going to do because he's been in jail twice now and this is
the third one and a girl.
Yeah,
a pretty little girl like that.
She's tiny man.
A hundred pounds.
Yeah.
You don't like to speculate on how the salon,
let's change subject.
It's distance.
It's a weird one too.
You know,
not just this topic,
but it's strange.
Like I like to analyze fighting.
I don't really like to be an MMA journalist because a lot of that time you're
not talking about fighting,
guys are talking about this guy said that thing or this sold that many things
are,
you know,
why is this guy not a star?
I don't care really about that shit so much.
Like to me I'm just just so unbelievably curious of what is going to happen when
Demetrius Johnson fights this guy.
And then after he fights sat guy sitting there and trying to figure out what the
thing was that made that one moment like you know Jaron Vol?
Yes.
Yeah Jaron vol was,
was a reffing that match.
We talk about bad ras who talking about bad judges.
We,
Jaron is cool and I ran into him in Winnipeg actually Joe Dirksen was at this
party and you were talking about the guys that Kinda,
you know,
our cool Dirksen works now in a prison and he said,
God,
she'll be like,
I think I can beat you.
And he'll be like,
yeah,
you probably could.
My,
Joe doesn't give a shit,
but,
uh,
they're Jaron Vilas there.
And he was saying,
I really like your Demetrius Johnson breakdown.
I'm like,
thanks man.
Whenever anybody's like likes those,
it means a lot to me cause I,
I'd love doing them.
Right.
And so we're talking about,
he goes,
well,
you know,
tell me what else you saw and where I'm having a beer and I whatever.
And uh,
I said,
why?
And he goes,
well,
I was,
I was wrapping that one.
So I did.
I looked at a lot of tape to,
and I'm like,
really?
That's cool man.
He goes,
yeah,
me and big John,
him and John are very good friends.
They'll go on Skype and look at tape together.
And so I'm like,
wow,
that's fucking cool that you do that.
And he goes,
yeah,
I saw a couple of things.
How one thing you didn't,
he didn't say you missed,
but he suggested and it was fucking brilliant.
Like this referee that was wrapping the main event picked up on this one.
That basically when the two guys,
when when Demetrius Johnson ends up kind of in that center zone,
not quite the clinch and not quite at,
at uh,
you know,
in the pocket,
kind of in that middle zone,
he'll give you a little bit shop.
Like he'll come see,
yeah,
well he,
he is looking for one of your only two logical responses.
You're going to back up and he backs all the way out or you're going to push
against his,
and he goes to the clinch.
So he goes in as a little sample test and he does it all after Jaron pointed
out,
I'm like,
holy fuck.
I looked at his fights.
He always does that.
And for a co a referee to go and spend that much time and find that little
moment because,
and I said,
why did you do that?
Because,
well,
I just wanted to be in the right moment and right places and be aware of what
was going on.
I'm like,
that's a fucking good.
That's uh,
that's what we need.
Yeah.
That is what we need.
And get an actual example in Demetrius Johnson of a guy who's trained by one of
the best in the world.
And Matt Hume.
I did a breakdown a Matt Hume's first fight in Pancrase.
Oh yeah.
I'm a big man.
Whom Fan?
I really like him in the corner too.
Yeah,
he's great at giving look technical instructions in between rounds.
I think you know there's a few guys that are just really good trainers and you
just see it in the,
in the examples of the fight.
Duane Ludwig I think right now is the best.
I don't think there's a better striking coach on earth.
Duke at Duke has him.
He's right up there with them.
Right up there with them.
You can,
Henri Hooft are in this world of perfection and bang,
Ludwig is pushing the boundaries a little.
He's trying to task is taking new things.
Even just the simplest shit that he was showing me,
uh,
after,
was it after or before Tj fight?
I think it was before.
And he was showing me the elements of when guys will go to enter and you know
how like I'll use punches to get you to think up and down and you start
responding up and down.
He makes you believe that he is playing with your up and down and while your
brain is focusing in on that,
he camouflages his footwork in.
So some of the punches are bullshit to make you think about them while he steps
off in a different place.
Yeah.
Shit like that.
Like and it's,
and he's a man and he is operating like he's got 700 cups of coffee and he's
yelling at his thinking fast and you can see,
talk about flow when he's teaching.
This guy's in a different place.
Yeah,
he really is.
Yeah.
Duane Ludwig,
chugs Alpha brain.
That shit like candy.
He eats it all day long.
He's obsessed with,
he's obsessed with analyzing fights and training fighters.
It's such a huge part of his daily thought process.
It's it,
it,
it just,
it's engrossing.
It just is.
It's his whole being and that's why he's so God damn good.
I sat down with him at lunch the day TJ fought Barao and when Tj Dillashaw beat
Hanan Barao,
who at the time was thought of as the best pound for pound fighter or one of the
best pound for pound for pound fighters in the world.
Tj was a big underdog and Tj went into that fight and dominated Hennen Browne
knocked him out in the fifth round after dropping them the first dominating them
for five rounds and then stopped him.
But what was crazy was when I had lunch with Dwayne,
Dwayne told me exactly what the plan was and then he went out and
did it exactly that way.
A lot of switching stances,
a lot of capitalizing on Barao loading up and standing flat footed,
a lot of stepping to the outside.
Then immediately countering and he did it over and over and over again.
And TJ is a sponge man.
I had a chance to watch those to workout together.
Tj is just a sponge.
He's a sponge.
Everything Duane teaches them.
Yeah.
Sometimes it's like,
do you got the brilliant teacher and the brilliant fighter and then the two
together make an even bigger thing.
And there's no conflict between those guys.
They're really good friends and Tj is a completely open book.
He,
his cup is empty and Dwayne is completely ego free when it comes to teaching
him.
He's all about getting TJ better.
Tj is all about getting better and they're great friends.
These guys love each other.
So they're always laughing and joking and palled around together.
Like when Tj beat Hanan Barao and there was this moment after the fight where
they hugged and they're both crying Israel.
Woo fucking real man.
I was tearing up when I was watching it,
a cage side.
It was crazy.
Amazing.
Yeah,
it was incredible.
I really wise and Demetrius and Matt Hume,
similar thing.
I look back,
it was 1994,
it was like four months after UFC one.
And I and I went back and reanalyze cause we,
uh,
up at fight network,
we're calling classic pancreas.
So we got all of the old pancreas and were commentating them through the lens of
today.
So we're going,
you know,
this guy does this.
Wow.
You know,
in 2014 that couldn't happen because of this,
this and this.
So we're looking at them historically in the context of today.
It's super cool,
man.
It's the funnest thing.
Like guys don't,
there's no such thing as a,
like if I,
if I got lots of pasture guard,
he just passes it.
Like in the 90s,
everyone's good at foot locks.
For some reason people change,
you get them out and you'll like swing your leg over the top to go back to side.
So I'm in the map,
my leg over to end up aside,
you'll be an eight,
10 different positions.
Always kind of,
there were chaining together a submission attempts in positions to try to make
you keep guessing,
but it didn't like it had over straight.
It's welcome.
You're looking at it and going,
this doesn't work,
but they're still doing it.
Yeah,
well no,
it's fascinating.
Dog Shit.
Jujitsu.
I watched,
uh,
I watched coliseum 2000 with Hixon Gracie,
over his house like way back.
And I kind of say it was probably like 2004 or 2005 or something like that.
It was back when Hickson was still thinking about fighting.
And it was a few years after he had fought food knocky and coliseum and he's,
we're watching fights together.
We watched the entire event and Hixon would break down the movements and he's
like,
look at all these space,
all this,
you can have this space,
you know,
like this like space to him it's just evil.
Like what is this?
You know,
cause Hickson's Jujitsu has always been the elite of the elite.
So when he watches like these errors and these things like big goofy movements,
you know,
with big openings,
he would just drive him crazy.
Like he would just be talking about all these errors and what's wrong with this
and so focused on it.
And if you watch Jujitsu or you watch MMA from 93 and then watch
like say Demetrius Johnson in 2014 you're like,
boy,
this is like no sport has evolved as quickly.
Never.
And you those two examples.
It's when I looked at Matt Hume,
he was better than everybody him and have Ventana.
We're better than everybody just because they were fighting like today.
And you look back and Matt Hume was doing this kind of leg ride and side ride,
like resting position that at that Chris Weidman was teaching at a seminar I was
at like two years ago and he's doing it in 1994 good morning ty to mad,
humid.
Very good morning time.
Remember he fought pat Miletich and broke his nose and they stopped the fight.
That was crazy.
Like stopped the fight for a broken nose.
I know,
I remember like thinking like what kind of Goofy Shit is that?
You look back at these pancreas ones too and it's like there were rope escapes.
Like if you go and it's like you've got it,
I'm fucking top.
Instead of tapping,
I grabbed the rope and then were stood up and it's like if it is not finished
you win.
Cause I grabbed the rope once but we've tried to figure that out.
I was going to talk to Dave Meltzer,
right,
who I don't really know good.
But you know we've chatted online and stuff cause he understands that history
moment because there's also a lot of works back then like legitimately and you
when you see works for folks who don't know,
we're talking about what mean fixed fights and that's a lot of,
that has a history because of pro wrestling.
Pro Wrestling in Japan was huge and that's also where the rope escape came from.
There was always like a big thing in pro wrestling.
The guy would have a hold on a god that God would grab the rope and the referee
would make them break.
It was a way to keep pro-wrestling.
Interesting.
Well when we look back at it,
we suddenly Ram Deena and I are colonies and we look at each other.
That's,
that's fake.
And some,
the first time that happened we were like,
well like I mean we have to address that week.
Like your credibility demands that you don't go,
oh and he power bombed them.
I mean you can't do that yet.
And you're talking about history.
We're trying to make this series a history lesson as well.
Right?
So you have to talk about it.
So they,
the reason it looks,
the way it looks,
you,
you nailed it.
It's like basically wrestling was fake.
Once upon a time.
Wrestling was real,
guys went to towns and they wrestled each other and the winner was the winner
who could wrestle.
But what's the guy's got so good and it got so boring that they had to fix them
and became progressive.
Is that why they did it?
Because God's got so good or is it just because people wanted to control the
outcome?
I think a bit of both because it's more gambling than anything.
Maybe so.
Yeah.
Uh,
and then progressing over there,
these two guys for knocky and Suzuki went and said,
well,
you're going to take pro wrestling,
which we love and everyone loves and we're going to make it real.
And so when they made it real,
that was Pancrase.
So suddenly it's like wrestling was real,
then it was fake and now we're going to make it real again.
So there were things like rope escapes left in there as you trans,
as you transferred from fake to real again.
They stayed there for a bit.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
That's really interesting.
And they were so obsessed with the storylines because they were originally
rustling performers that the most of the work's involved them and involve them
losing.
So in its in its own way,
it was only there to create,
but it's a weird time in there like for purists and I fucking love the sport.
You have to make sense of why that was for people so that they're not just,
it doesn't color MMA in a way,
but it was that moment where I'm a man.
Wrestling sort of touched each other in the early nineties
yeah,
that is an interesting thing,
man.
It's also an interesting thing that I,
we were saying this that I don't think there's ever been a sport that has
changed so much and grown so much in just a period of 20 years.
Like this 20 if you go to UFC one and then go to one on one number,
we all know,
or (707) 087-0870 seven if you go and just go to 2014 2003 or 1993 to 2014 it's
gone through like a thousand years of evolution that the level is so different.
The level of athleticism,
the level of endurance,
the martial arts skill,
like everything's different.
Everything's different.
I I,
I think it's one of the things I love about it the most and like people will
talk John Johnson and core me a or like having all this heat and they asked me
about it.
It's like,
well I don't care.
It's interesting.
But for me the biggest thing about one of the,
I always say the biggest thing,
cause I also love the science.
I also love the brain chemistry.
I love the beauty of the dance,
all of it.
But one of the things I'm most interested in is it's basically one global
science experiment in real time using thousands and thousands and thousands of
fights to distill down to the nugget of what's the best and it's still is that
every 500 fights,
the best coaches are going,
okay,
well that doesn't work anymore.
Well we've added that.
That works and it's just ongoing distillation down to the purest way to beat
other guys.
That changes slightly now because of this sort of demand for entertainment from
the audience and stuff that changes.
Like you know,
guys are rewarded more for standing now than in certain things so that Ultracet
but you re you take that out of it and basically we just have thousands and
thousands of contests all there to help us determine the research of how to be
the best fighter.
Yeah,
I have issue with that aspect of it.
The were the technical aspect of fights changes for it to be more entertaining.
I think it's not good.
I think it's not smart and I think it takes away from the purity of mixed
martial arts expression.
Like what?
What is martial arts?
It's all about doing the very best thing in order to win a fight.
And if you put yourself more in danger so the crowd roars and you know,
like just drop your hands,
Duke it up.
I remember a guy who was a friend of mine wrote something on Twitter and he
wrote a,
you know,
fuck technical striking,
just stand in the center of the cage and let it bang.
And meanwhile the guy who wrote that is all fucked up.
Now he's got all sorts of physical problems.
He's had a bunch of fights,
he's all banged up and it's like,
no,
don't know.
Don't think that,
don't say that.
Like put,
that's the,
that is like,
you know,
like uh,
fuck,
fuck thinking I'm just going to hit this with a hammer.
No,
no.
You have to think like that's the whole thing.
The whole thing is solving the puzzle and solving the puzzle in striking is
about technical striking.
It doesn't mean no knockouts.
There's a lot of knockouts that come from tactical strikers.
It's means doing it the right way where you have the most amount of success,
the least amount of risk and you're doing things based on the amount of
knowledge that's been accumulated over thousands of years of martial arts.
You were applying that and intelligent way Johnson,
Demetrius Johnson in my opinion is the best example of that.
That fucking guy does everything right.
Everything he does is perfect.
He doesn't rush anything.
He's never seen him slugging it out and then fucking drop it his hands and like
come on bitch,
come on.
But there's none of that stupidity.
It's all brilliant martial arts and he's so exciting to watch.
I mean I I,
you know sometimes people say it's not as exciting cause you just not finishing
guys as much,
but he fucking finished John Moraga and the fourth round of a fight that he was
dominating.
He finished Joseph Benevidez one punch guy in the world in this way.
Exactly.
You know,
he's a beast and Bhagwati enough,
the only reason why I didn't finish him cause he's EPO to the fucking gills and
who knows what else.
Yeah.
I mean he is such a part of it.
Yes.
It's such an enormous part of it.
If you are,
you know,
if everything is else's equal but you're in better shape than the guy eventually
it's no longer he mall.
It's really that simple.
Well,
that's the Nick Diaz strategy.
Nick Diaz Strategy.
Nick is obviously a very high level martial artist when it comes to his
technique and his experience and he's obviously very,
very tough guy,
but he's also in fucking phenomenal shave.
Nick Diaz is swam back from Alcatraz twice in the fucking Pacific Ocean outside
San Francisco,
filled with sharks.
Okay.
He swam back twice.
He's done triathletes,
triathlons.
He's done marathons.
I mean he's a fucking beast when it comes to his physical conditioning and what
he does is just puts a pace.
He just makes you run with them like,
come on,
let's go.
We'll go and run and we're going running and he starts throwing these punches
that are like 50% speed.
Hey,
come catch me coming.
Killing mentally get you pulled in there.
He's good at that too.
Oh yeah.
He starts,
come on bitch.
Come on bitch.
That gets you vial.
Oh,
it's brilliant.
You Know Jack Slack.
Sure.
Yeah man.
That guy is doing killer stuff.
Excellent stuff.
Yeah,
great breakdowns.
A little group of people at their to niche in a niche and I'm proud to be part
of it.
Mine,
I stand there and do mine.
But Jack is fucking good.
And this young Guy Lawrence Kenshin is,
yes,
I was going to mention him.
Excellent.
Great breakdowns.
And I'm so happy that like there's these guys doing it and instead of God who's
that fucking guy,
I'm better than him whether we end up kind of we're friends.
So it Kinda like pushing each other.
It's really,
it's an interesting thing about MMA commentary that's like that as well.
Like I'm really good friends with Michael.
She'll velo really good friends with Jimmy Smith.
I worked with Mike twice,
good friends with Jason Chambers as well.
He's a great buddy
and because I'm friends with all these guys that also do my job,
like there's no like competition amongst each other.
Like I tried to get Jimmy Smith hired by the UFC.
Oh,
I tell you,
when Jimmy Smith was,
his contract was going up with Bella tour,
I called Dana White and I said,
dude,
this guy's the best.
He's great.
He's really good.
He's a real martial artist.
He's a real good guy.
I go,
he should work for us.
You know,
he's,
he's fucking great.
Okay.
Balachandra must've understood he was so valuable.
Well,
they would.
Yeah,
they were.
Well,
they were worried also.
They would worry that who the fuck else is out there.
I mean,
it's a really tough Gig to have a person who's very passionate and very
articulate,
which Jimmy is both and it's really good at breaking down scenarios and
situations and is legitimately passionate while the fights going on.
Like you could see it.
And also not afraid to call out bad refereeing,
bad calls,
bad judgements.
And he's really like it.
It's very important to him to be honest about the whole scene.
There's not that many guys out there.
So if they,
if Bella did lose Jimmy,
like who the fuck else?
Who Do they get all my fights?
Yeah,
they probably would call you and you would do a great job.
I'm sure.
I mean that Brian Stan does a great job.
That's Kenny Florian of course,
does a great job
guy.
He's always been one of my favorites because he's a regular guy who just figured
out how to get the answers to the shit he needed to get to.
You know what I mean?
Like he wasn't some big powerful genetic specimen.
Right.
He was kind of a nerd who's like,
if I can just figure out how to do this.
Okay,
that worked.
But this didn't and overtime and he analyzes the same way.
But where I was going with Jack talking about Jack is he did this,
I'm sure Tim,
I'm remembering this amazing breakdown on um,
Nick Diaz.
Yes.
And I'm pretty sure it was jack.
If it isn't,
if it was a different guy,
I apologize,
but it's looking at Nick Diaz is striking compared to old school bare knuckle
boxers.
You know,
the guys who were the mustaches fighting like this and it looks at it and
there's so many comparisons.
Weighed on the front leg,
catching punches with the top of his head.
Like so many.
It's so brilliant at,
I'm pretty,
it must be Jack.
Cause Jack the best guy out there.
Yeah,
he's done a bunch of great stuff.
Yeah.
He even wrote a,
he wrote a whole piece on George Saint Pierre Versus Nick Diaz,
which is in advance of it or after.
Yeah.
I believe it was in advance and,
and he wrote a breakdown afterwards.
He writes
bunch of those things,
man.
He's got,
yeah,
he's writing.
Part of the reason he's so good is he's working so much.
He's in that zone,
you know,
but nobody knows who he really is.
And uh,
does anybody know what he looks like?
No,
I think he,
I mean he doesn't want that and I think that's super cool.
I think he's British.
I'm pretty sure he's,
I believe he has too.
But uh,
it's cool man.
It's a little niche but people are finding it interesting.
I always feel like,
you know,
you look at other sports and on Monday the ESPN will have a two hour show and
they will go into what happened.
And it won't be like,
well this guy threw a thing and the the highlight will only be the catch the
show,
what happened at the line.
They'll show,
they'll talk about what kind of plays these guys calling and stuff.
That kind of analysis,
like all you guys do a fucking killer job,
but the before and the after and that's an area I was wishing the UFC
concentrated on more,
especially during the really passion years.
Like the,
the heavy work has always been on the hype and the excitement and this guy hates
and these two are the best and stuff.
But during that era you feel like if you got 20% or 30% or 40% of the audience
to be obsessed with the technique.
And I think a lot of times people went and showed how to do a triangle,
not how to watch a triangle.
You know what I mean?
You know?
But it feels like in a lot of other sports there are,
they have spent time to develop a PR,
a certain percentage of the audience that is there because baseball does some
crazy shit.
I Dunno what happens in baseball,
but there are guys that talk about how the field moves and what guys do when
they're like with Rosin and shit and if football they talk about how the plays
are called,
what the subtleties are and you don't see that before and after in the UFC.
Yeah,
I agree with you know,
it'd be nice to see that they're doing a lot of that though on the,
uh,
the breakdowns that they do on Fox,
on Fox sports,
like Carlos condit does a fantastic job of that.
No,
I'm not going to say Carlos condit other than me and Carlos condit.
Who the fuck who the,
who does that?
Um,
Dominick Cruz.
Donald Cruz does a great job of it
to speak in like you're talking about Tom,
Demetrius Johnson,
Dominick Cruz.
If he can come back the way that he was,
he's one of those super brilliant mind blowing performance too.
Yeah.
Well,
he's,
he's great as far as movement,
foot work and his conditioning is always top notch to Dominic is just so good at
like not being there like you,
you,
you swing for him and he's off to the left and then he's countering you off to
the right and you're like,
fuck him.
Where is this guy?
But he does a great job.
Like he did a great breakdown of Lee versus a rich Franklin explaining it drew
out the right hook.
Yeah,
I did a great job of explaining like,
you know when,
when someone is like,
like head straight up in the air and they don't move off the center line.
That shit drives me crazy.
I watched it.
I was like,
fucking who's training you like why are you like,
what's going on here?
And then you watch a guy like TJ Dillashaw so satisfying because he does all the
right things because he's constantly moving off the center line because he's
completely unpredictable.
So like when Dominic did a great,
he did a great breakdown,
what Franklin did wrong and where the errors were.
And he's done that for a bunch of different fights.
Don was really good at it.
Yeah.
He's fucking talented.
Uh,
there,
uh,
went into,
we were talking about Duane Ludwig,
when he's teaching,
he'll say,
you make no errors unless you're making them on purpose.
And what he means by that is if you,
obviously you show,
oh,
this is here and the guy will throw a punch.
We want them to do that and we'll respond.
And there was,
there's a really wild heavy case of it where you see,
and I broke it down and,
and uh,
if you even just look at the fight itself,
you see it as soon as somebody I mentioned it was,
um,
Jack Ira versus a Okami,
right?
So shock Caray the whole fight,
all he's got in mind is the overhand right.
And the way for him to draw that out is,
you know,
how everybody who,
are they talking about that,
where the front foot goes,
you know,
against a southpaw.
He's got his front foot intentionally inside and he's offering a straight line
to his chin for the straight left.
And it'll call me.
You can see him seeing it and going,
Nah Shit,
he wants me to throw that,
oh shit he's doing,
he's ready to counter it.
And the hesitation on Okami is like,
it's such a fascinating moment as a guys go going,
look,
I'm out here or you can hit me with it.
And he's going,
oh he's telling me I can hit him with it.
But he's got that right hand ready.
And then just those moments to me are the fascinating shit.
Well it's also even more fascinating,
it comes to garlic joc arrays because if you do engage the real fears that he's
going to take you down.
Yeah,
there's always this thing when you're striking with a guy who such an elite
grappler.
It's like this guy is trying to goad me into a slug fest,
but I know that he's going to change levels and take me down at any moment.
So you're always hesitant to really commit the shots and extend yourself.
Cause if you extend yourself,
it makes it much more difficult to defend a take down.
A guy like Okami is also,
or a guy like Jacques Rey rather is also fascinating because started out his
career as one of the elite of the elite and grappling and really at bad striking
in the beginning like you watch is when he got knocked out by Makoko.
Just his striking was just very rudimentary,
which wasn't very good.
But now he's destroying guys with striking.
Like he beat the fucking shit out of you can,
okay,
you should know Cami with striking and like that's terrifying to people because
now you take this guy who is this just phenomenal top 1% of all grapplers ever.
I mean I think John like lead Jujitsu guys,
he's like top 1% ever and now destroying people with stand up.
It's like the focus that made him a great Jujitsu fighter and the athleticism is
now making him an elite striker and that's
terrified that what I have,
it's always kind of an additional terrifying is that you don't see him for like
a year when a guy's not around for a year.
You're like,
what the fuck is he doing?
Right?
Like what does he have now?
What new things does he have?
Right.
What does he do better?
What's way faster than it was a year ago?
That always scares the shit out of me.
Likes excites you and there's a fight coming,
but you're like,
shit man.
What has this guy been doing in the lab for the last year?
Maybe he's got some crazy shit we don't even know about.
Yeah,
well he's definitely getting better.
He's not slacking off.
I guarantee you that.
But did you see when he got elbow surgery and they cleaned out his elbow,
did you see that?
Oh,
oh,
pull that up.
Jamie Shakuri Elbow surgery pictures he had before he fought Francis Garment.
Um,
he had uh,
like be like a really bad but like bone spurs and chips and shit inside of his
elbow.
It was like,
you know,
all the years of elbowing people and also of getting arm barred,
like things break off inside your elbow and it becomes like crunchy and you're
moving it around.
It's just all inflammation and tissue damage.
And,
and look,
we'll show it to you up on the big screen,
but it's really fucking crazy.
Like
cop,
ah,
things,
oh they removed from his elbow,
got teeth in his album out.
It looks like teeth
chunks of bone and cartilage and all rip it apart.
All the stuff around and on top.
You know what people don't,
you know,
how could they,
but nobody really sees a guy like who's a black belt level guys,
but training you guys,
you and Eddie and and a shot at least black belt level guys train all their
life.
They have no idea what that does to their joints and their bodies like Jiu
Jitsu,
so fucking fit,
vicious sport.
Like it's a hard vicious sport.
Guys will kickboxers we'll look over at the Jujitsu area and they see the guys
stretching and stuff and like,
oh look these guys,
they won't,
they don't want no part of that.
They don't want to go in there,
have the skeleton all stacked by a guy like yeah it's a vicious sport
or that I'm realizing like one of the things that I did,
I made some mistakes with my Jujitsu training and one of the mistakes that I
made was for a long time I didn't do any strength and conditioning equipment.
There's strength and conditioning training.
I did mostly just Jujitsu like for years and years I would lift ways like maybe
once a week or something like that.
I get a little lift in just to kind of maintain my strength and size,
but I didn't specifically like strengthen my core strength and my spine,
strengthen certain areas and strach constantly stretch.
Like you got to put as much time almost into that as you do in your Jujitsu
training just to armor up your body just to,
just to armor up your joints,
not so that you can overpower guys and like not concentrate on technique,
which a lot of people do have a problem with like really strong like football
players.
Big guys tend to try to muscle things instead of like the really technical guys
are always the really small guys because they don't have the muscle up option.
So their option is only do use the proper technique and leverage.
But you,
the strengthening your body is important just to prevent injuries,
strengthen your hamstrings to prevent knee injuries,
strengthen your quads,
prevent knee injuries,
strengthening your neck,
strengthening your back,
like strengthened lower back stretching.
All that's like a lot of guys slack off on that Shit.
And I did too.
And I got some,
some pretty serious back injuries because of that,
because I wasn't strengthening those areas.
You know,
like for the longest time I very rarely worked my back.
I didn't do like rose or any like exercises specifically.
So having like an issue with disks and stuff like that forced me to really
concentrate on that.
Yeah,
that's nasty stuff.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
guys get back injuries,
head gets the doctors give him like opiates and stuff.
That shit can wreck their lives.
Oh,
bad back injury leads to something like that.
And next thing you know,
you're,
you're Tanya flading dudes for money for,
hey,
how'd you get there?
It was a lot,
bit of a leap I recognize.
But what does your,
what is your martial arts background?
When did you start doing martial arts?
I started by nine a taekwondo.
I have a black belt in taekwondo.
I trained through Canada.
Oh,
Toronto.
Yeah,
a chaos Cho College.
I lived,
grew up in Manitoba and you know what,
like my parents are the coolest people ever on earth.
I was just like a weird kid and I really was like Bruce Lee and stuff.
Like I was really interested in martial arts.
The end.
I was pretty hyper and odd and it didn't have a lot of focus.
And they once they said,
if you're serious about this,
we'll do it.
They would drive me an hour and a half each direction to Winnipeg to go train
three times a week for my whole fucking as a kid.
It was amazing.
It changed my whole Byron's mom.
It changed my whole life.
And,
uh,
you know,
I competed,
I did really well and stuff and,
and I enjoyed it and I did a little box,
I had an interest in every martial art,
so I did a little sicker on which is like a Filipino martial arts sicker on,
how do you spell it's s,
And you know,
no,
rns and Colleen are an offshoot of sicker on what's a Filipino martial arts and
it's very much like taekwondo.
But when they compete they stick their hands in their belt and it's mall spin
kicks in,
Hook kicks and shit.
It's super cool.
They put their hands,
they compete like wide stance with their head far back,
lots of hook kicks off the front and the no hands,
it's a kicking,
it's like savant almost savant does have hands now modified to have hands over
time.
But,
but so I did a lot of that at our,
no walking,
no all moving your head and your body.
It was like really,
it was just a very Winnipeg thing.
This one central area of,
of Canada,
this Filipino master of it came there and he started the school.
He was a really good businessman so it ended up being on in the whole world.
If you looked at were sick around,
was taught the Philippines and there was a chunk,
a little red.in the middle of Canada because this guy was there and he had a
bunch of schools and people study it.
A lot of Filipino population.
So I did a little of that and then we have to stick around.
It's really cool.
Check it out.
I don't know how much they'll be a modern stuff on the internet,
but it's basically a ton of round kicks,
Hook kicks and spin kicks with your weight heavy on the back leg.
So it's sort of like kicking like a martial arts version of soccer.
Yeah.
Use your hands like fencing with your feet.
You want me to look?
You can't even like block.
That's so ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
I mean,
but his boxing or did cause you can only punch.
Yeah,
but at least you can block.
I guess that actually you would see a lot of cars over the IOWAS found it
interesting.
Even just as a kid I was curious guys would be doing,
you'd go to the tournament's in guys are all doing hook kicks and then shift
forward and spin kick.
All of a sudden guys started doing this from there where they would just bounce
on their back leg cooking and,
and round kicking.
So they bounced towards each other during that.
So they're tapping.
It's just an interesting thing as a teenager to see.
And then I got,
I started playing in a rock band in my 20th since I didn't do much martial arts
at all.
Afternoon practice music before that.
Like when did you get involved in I was uh,
growing up as a kid,
Bruce Lee and Alice Cooper were like my two,
the Glam rock
and a late mid twenties.
I started playing in a band and I really like performing and I did a lot of
jumping and kicking and wearing tight pants and you know,
I like it was superior.
The Rostow exactly,
exactly.
And,
uh,
somewhere.
But June David Lee Roth in the New York dolls and very drunk,
very,
very fucked up like through the whole era.
Like we would go and we,
oh man.
And I told Eddie this story.
I haven't told a lot of people this story but people ask me about it if my
friends ask me about it recently,
but I was basically on tour so I can do that for like 10,
12,
14 years and we were touring England in the UK and um,
and uh,
like,
um,
it'll leave in a few places like that.
We did really well over there and I had a seizure from just doing so much drugs
and drinking so much and like a bad,
like you basically I had been the,
when I came back the doctor said the vodka and red bull was actually the biggest
component.
The fact that I took a lot of speed over the three days without sleeping,
let me drink more vodka,
red ball.
But basically as the sugar leaves your body,
it goes down and you and you get sick.
And when the alcohol then leaves her body,
it draws more sugar and you have a hypoglycemic seizure.
So I lied laying on the couch.
I felt terrible for like 10 hours and then all of a sudden apparently I just
yelled something and people came over and I felt this electricity shoot down my
arms into my hands and they just locked up and I rolled back down in my eyes,
rolled in my head.
I thought it was 10 seconds later and everyone's looking at me like I just got
knocked out,
you know?
And then apparently it was like a minute or something.
And I went back and the doctor said,
dude,
you got to get your life together.
And I started training martial arts again pretty much that day.
And then I trained,
you know,
three times a week,
then five,
then seven,
then I was doing Jujitsu Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday,
7:00 AM noon and 6:00 PM and Tuesday and Thursday noon and 6:00 PM and you were
trained to do two,
three times a day,
Monday,
Wednesday,
Friday,
twice a day,
Tuesday,
Thursday for about six months.
And then people kind of knew me a little in Canada,
like on television doing stuff.
I was like a reality show judge.
And the network said,
Oh,
you're going to fight.
Well,
why don't we do a TV show about that?
And that kind of allowed me,
I really want it to be in the fight world.
That's what I love.
The second I kind of had,
you know,
been not living a crazy lifestyle.
All I wanted to do was martial arts and then real really from that minute on and
that's all I kind of did.
And that's all I was interested in.
Wow.
That's crazy that you blacked out from red bull and vodka.
So the hypoglycemic aspect of it is just super bad for you.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They,
uh,
in fact out,
and my wife just told me this morning,
unrelated,
she said she was on the Internet and she said,
uh,
Toronto looking to ban vodka or alcohol and red bull served in bars just,
just popped up this morning on the Internet.
That's so crazy.
I never thought of that as a bad drink.
Yeah.
At the very dangerous,
this apparently law.
Once you,
something like that happens to you,
you look it up on the Internet,
there's a lot of that going on.
HYP hypoglycemic seizures as a result
of vodka.
Redbulls that's so funny.
Well,
when it's hypoglycemia,
what have you used?
Sugar free.
Red Bull.
Does it have a lesson than hell?
Yeah.
Help you come to try and give me,
give me the equaling folks.
Give it a go.
I feel like,
um,
it's always like a weird thing when you mix an upper and a downer too.
Right?
And that's what you're doing with alcohol and red bull.
If you smoke a better weed and you strike a coffee,
it's kind of on the same thing.
Not really though,
because I don't think weed is a downer.
It's not a downer in terms of like a depressant.
Alcohol is a true depressant.
Yeah.
We'd like you could smoke a joint and lift weights and have a great work.
I can't,
you can't.
You need to hang out with me more.
Yeah,
maybe so.
Oh Man.
Want to do,
it's like chill out.
I'll watch fights all to a bit of writing or whatever.
But yeah,
I tend to get a little introverted,
little mellow.
I Dunno.
It's just,
you know,
it's fantastic.
We'd and yoga.
Yeah,
that would make sense to me.
For Asia,
it's amazing stretching like a,
I was talking to my friend Aubrey about this the other day that like a,
there's this buddy that we know that,
um,
makes these,
uh,
they're called jam bows,
these uh,
organic,
um,
uh,
edibles,
but he uses honey instead of like a processed sugar and the really delicious and
they're super strong and you know,
Aubrey eight one and then went on this like two hours stretching.
And like rampage was like,
oh,
like using a lacrosse ball to roll out all the,
the tight tissue just makes you really in tune.
It makes you feel like,
well,
I like lifting weights on it because it makes me like feel like what my body's
doing.
I feel like I can get like a sense of better,
I'm more in tune,
more sensitive.
I'd be afraid of afraid,
but I don't feel like doing something physical.
But I'd definitely give it a track.
Uh,
it's weightlifting for you.
That's become like a martial art,
right?
It is to me,
I think of especially Olympic lifting,
that's a martial art.
In what way?
Like an Olympic lifts,
like say,
um,
you know,
a clean or a snatch,
you work for forever on the little details to try to make yourself calm enough
to be able to express yourself with the lift,
like to be able to really put it all together.
You move one way wrong.
You don't,
you don't nail the lift.
You distributor wait different in your feet.
You don't know the left.
You don't drive and tire hips together with the same time that you're supposed
to go up on your toes and shrug.
He don't hit the left.
So it becomes this ongoing work to try to make this thing better.
And a man like to doing an Olympic clean to me is one of the great things in the
world to be able to just really hit.
Yeah.
It's such a full body exercise too.
It's such,
it's like really enhances your ability to explode anytime you're doing anything
where you're pushing up from your toes,
from the ground and extending and lifting it up over your head and forcing your
whole body go fucking power that up.
Everything,
your whole chain,
your posterior,
your,
your all your,
your uh,
your,
your core,
your spine.
Like can you think of your shoulder,
your delts,
your,
your quads,
your toes,
your toes are pushing.
That's why like a Steve Maxwell is a big proponent of lifting weights barefoot.
Yeah.
He thinks that,
you know,
when you have,
uh,
like especially a spongy
Servo,
like a running shoe on with,
it's like a lot of give that you're not feeling,
you don't,
you're,
you're not engaging your toes pushing off the ground.
I'll say take away some of your force.
Some of them for sure.
Exerting it will kind of absorb it a little bit.
Yeah,
definitely.
They,
a lot of the Olympic lifters around where I go,
I go to this place,
Bang fitness in Toronto and it's just like,
it's the best part of my week to go in there.
And,
um,
they had most of the guys who Olympic lift just use the tiny,
tiny,
tiny shoe sole.
Yeah,
I like those.
A lot of people criticize those toe shoes,
you know,
apparently they made a bunch of ridiculous claims that aren't necessarily true,
but I still like it.
I love them for lifting weights.
They're so comfortable for lifting weights and again,
the same thing.
They're really flat and they make you feel,
I liked the fact that the toes are all free moving because you can push off with
those things.
You feel like your connection to the ground.
But yeah,
I'm a big fan of Olympic lifts.
I'm a big fan of obviously of kettle bells.
I'm a big fan of anything where you're doing these explosive strength exercises.
This make your body so much God damn strong,
feel good doing that.
That you know,
you talk about drug or or whatever.
It's like you get endorphins from doing full body that's,
hey,
have you ever seen that tab on the Internet?
These kinesiologists broke down in like milliseconds.
Bruce Lee's one inch punch.
Yeah.
Crazy.
And they show that it's actually the order in which his body fires and it's like
the millisecond,
the shred of a millisecond in between the different body parts kind of firing
one after the other.
It's fascinating.
It is fascinating.
You know I used to be a,
well I'm still,
I'm a huge fan of Mike Tyson,
but one of the things that I used to always be fascinated about Tyson then
people didn't comment on is his size of his fucking legs.
Like that's where all the power was coming from.
He was like pushing off the floor constantly,
like pushing off the floor and just everything was like thrusting from the
bottom and when you see a guy punching you assume like,
oh it's his body,
his upper body,
his arms are throwing the punch.
But really with like a guy like Tyson,
those vicious power punches.
It was all coming from his ass.
It was called from his toes down,
pushing off and all his quads and it's upper body throwing it into it.
It's amazing how much of that is,
how much of your,
your full body is involved in techniques and a kettle bell.
It's Olympic lifts,
stuff like that.
That way that that,
that the bottom half attaches to the top half.
That's strength in between those two.
That's the big,
definitely the big.
When you compete,
what way do you compete at one 35 whoa.
How do you make,
what do you walk around at?
Probably one 58 right now.
Wow.
That's a lot of drain yourself,
Huh?
Yeah.
I mean when I was fighting for me,
even at the beginning was trying to figure out what's going on,
like really understand it to a point that I can fairly analyze it and I really
felt like that I had to go in and do it.
Also,
you want to,
you become a better person going and doing that,
you know,
pushing,
you talked about it just today.
We are you pushing,
taking risks,
going in,
putting yourself in harm's way,
putting yourself at risk of failure.
I mean,
that's part of it,
but really it's to figure out stuff.
Being forced to make heavyweight as top going to weigh in a seeing I want to
kill you.
That's all of those experiences.
I think it helped.
My real calling of allies are fine.
Why did you decide to cut so much weight?
And it started out my first fight I probably walked around at 145 pounds and
then you cut weight and your next fight,
you're 148 pounds and then you cut all that weight and you come back and you
gain your 150 pounds and over.
I was also 39 when I took my first fight.
Now I'm 45.
So over the six years I gained three pounds a year just in muscle.
This,
yeah,
lifting weights,
working really hard,
changing my life from,
you know,
eating burgers and shit and drinking beer at lunch to working out twice a day
and,
and change all of that.
Just added three,
four pounds of muscle a year.
And each time you cut weight after you've gained the weight back,
you fought this.
And then,
uh,
you know,
you've had your couple of days to eat pizza and burgers and stuff.
The weight that you are then is a pound or two heavier than it was the last time
you were there.
Yeah,
at least it was for me.
Yeah.
At least.
So these guys,
at least maybe in your thirties and forties so a lot of these guys,
you know,
they either have a perfect,
and I was going to say they have a perfect diet,
but a lot of these guys celebrate the way that you deserve to celebrate after he
fought a fight and they don't have the perfect diet right after.
But it gets that walking around weight creeps up a little bit.
At least it did for me.
Well,
the lighter weight guys ascent,
traditionally,
those have been the guys that have the shortest careers.
Yeah.
The lighter weight guys,
when they get into their thirties it starts to drop off.
Whereas heavyweights in their thirties,
a lot of times they're just hitting their prime.
You know,
like you could have a heavyweight,
like look,
George Foreman won the heavyweight title at 45 years old,
46 actually,
and was the oldest heavyweight champion was the oldest boxing champion until
Bernard Hopkins recently,
which is just the freakiest freaks.
Yeah.
He's the strangest guy ever.
And he's amazing to me.
How do you get,
do you know him?
Have you got to no,
no,
no.
I need to meet him.
I've never met him,
but I've,
I've admired his style.
I just love,
I was amazed back when he beat Kelly Pavlock,
which is like,
what was that like 2007 or something like that.
You'd look seven years later,
it's still blowing people away.
Wow.
It is wild.
Um,
who's that football player that was fighting in a,
was it bell?
Herschel Walker?
Yeah.
You know what?
He was 48 when he was fighting in Strikeforce.
Yeah,
right.
Oh yeah.
I'm a strike force shredded.
I mean,
he was goddamn shredded and it just a beast at 48 and,
but Hershel Walker's something going on there that's not kosher.
I mean with his brain because like he says that he eats like a salad and drinks
a bowl of soup and a day and that's it.
That's not even possible to keep that kind of math.
Well,
I mean we could get some doctors and dieticians and they would 100% tell us
there's no way that could be true.
Right.
So when a guy tells you that all he eats is a salad and drinks a cup of soup
every day.
Okay.
I don't know what he's doing.
He might be fucking with people.
There's something not kosher about that though.
It's weird,
but he's so yoked.
It's also,
it's crazy to see that kind of muscle mass and a 48 year old guy like no loss of
muscle mass.
In fact like he looks,
he looks like a 25 year old guy in his prime.
The science,
I mean it is not cool to suggest that somebody is doing something but not
talking about him necessarily mean performance enhancing drugs.
But the science of many guys in their forties fifties sixties and seventies the
sciences there to make a 65 I mean we've all seen photos of a 70 year old guys
just shred.
It's the loan.
Yeah.
Yeah,
exactly.
So loan is like 67 years old now and he's a ripped.
I wish I had his body.
No,
crazy ridiculous.
It would be fascinating to get a real one of these guys on the front end of anti
aging and human performance side,
that science to figure out like,
okay,
a bodybuilder uses this much growth hormone.
A guy like say an actor on CSI maybe uses like this much,
you know like anti aging.
How much is this 70 how much is Stallone using?
You know what I mean?
To get a sense of where the chemistry is happening.
Is this more,
is this different?
Do you have the new shit that we don't know about?
Like what's going on at the elite level?
Like Stallone was.
I don't,
I mean,
he's not an athlete,
so it's,
it's not a big deal.
But he was caught at a airport once with a whole bunch of,
it was in Australia because it's illegal in Australia.
They have weird laws when it comes to hormones,
even hormones that are prescribed by doctors that don't show any negative
effects on the body when used at normal doses.
Meanwhile,
they have alcohol at every fucking store.
You know,
it's all corn.
Racy,
it's science.
It's fucking weird medicines where it's ignorance.
It's not the science or medicine.
That's weird.
It's the ignorance.
Well,
it's,
no,
it's the,
essentially the people that are dictating the rules,
the people that are writing the laws,
their ignorance about the understanding,
the effects of on the human body,
these substances out,
if it's done correctly.
And if it's done through proper medical supervision,
it enhances the body.
And that's what people don't understand.
When you arrest a guy like still own,
who's showing up with growth hormone and he's,
why don't you just let him take his shirt off and look?
Exactly.
The zoo look bad.
He's healthy.
He's happy.
His wife is good.
What exactly is going on here?
Yeah.
It's also,
it's not like he's competing in some sport.
We have some unfair advantage.
No,
he's an old guy who wants to have a body that works good and why is it okay that
that old guy could go to the bar and just do shot after shot until it's fucking
liver collapses and no one stops that,
but you have a problem with them bringing the inboxes of human growth hormone
just like it's weird.
It is weird.
It's for some reason people,
when something happens that people decide something is a,
a law or bad or they've made a decision on something,
it takes forever.
Change it.
Like even,
and people are anti science,
right?
They're anti science.
So this like you'd go,
no,
look these.
This is why this has got no,
because since the 60s we've said this is bad,
therefore it's bad.
Well,
I think when it comes to growth hormone and testosterone and all these different
things were the real,
where people have an issue is because the way it's played out in the public eye
has been all about illegal use in sports.
It's been about the Barry bonds situation.
It's been about Mark McGuire.
It's been about all these people that are taking these things in cheating in
sports.
So because our associations have been all about people getting unfair advantages
in sports,
people automatically assume that these substances are bad for you.
When you look at cigarettes,
which are one of the worst things for you ever,
no one's stopping that from being legal.
Those are everywhere
as people that make hundreds of billions lobby to make that stay leak,
you know,
like it's like I'm making $100 billion,
I got to get some,
some government person to say cigarettes is okay,
let's keep that cool.
You know,
that's,
it's motivated by finance.
Yeah.
But I mean,
I don't,
that's why I don't understand.
I mean,
so it was,
you could sell testosterone tomb and that can be motivated by finance as well.
It's just,
there's a big difference between the way people look at,
there should be a big difference between the way people look at someone who's
doing something that's a performance enhancing drug that's allowing them to
compete in an unfair advantage with an unfair advantage in a sport and doing it
where if you're a guy likes a restaurant Stallone,
you're doing it to enhance your life and you're 70 years old or whatever and
you're shredded.
Like who gives a shit?
Let the guy do whatever he wants.
Well what if,
you know,
there's an element of trying to let 10 keep a difference between the people at
the top and the people at the bottom.
What if the,
all the people at the bottom got testosterone that would be harder to manage
them harder to kind of,
you know,
like the societal difference between,
the oppressed,
the people who are kind of at the bottom of the food chain.
The people like the people who run a shit and the kind of people who kind of
monitor how the world kind of works.
Prefer to keep people watching TV.
Not really,
you know,
eating bad food that there's does smoking cigarettes.
There's a direction to keeping some of society not super active and those people
don't want those people to take performance enhancing drugs.
They want them to smoke cigarettes and eat hamburgers and shit.
I wonder if that's a real conscious decision.
You know,
there's,
that's a,
a thing that gets thrown around a lot.
That accusation gets thrown around that there's some sort of uh,
international cabal.
This look looking out to keep the proletariat down,
but not,
not so much saying that there's some room somewhere we're 20 guys are in there
making decisions.
Just the feeling,
the,
the sort of,
the way that society kind of breaks itself up if these laws happen for this
reason,
it keeps,
these guys are rich.
The way that society kind of Devy shit out.
It kind of ends up being that way.
I think you'd kind of ends up being that way more than anybody's trying to make
it that way.
Yeah.
I think that what would people have when it comes to testosterone and human
growth hormone and anti aging and all these,
the stigmas that people have on the,
whether that's the efficacy of them or the,
the dangers of them is a lot of it is based on sports.
It's a lot of his base on all the negative press that we've heard about guys
taking steroids in sports.
And then there's,
you know,
in MMA there's this huge issue with testosterone replacement therapy,
which was up until very recently legal now,
um,
human growth hormone has always been illegal,
but they were never testing for it until recently when shell son,
he got popped for human growth hormone.
It was a big deal.
Yeah.
Because it let everybody know like,
Oh boy,
these new tests,
like I had a conversation with jail about it right after he got popped.
He's like,
well,
turns out these new tests are really good.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's,
that's really what it was.
They're doing these tasks that costs $45,000 per athlete.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's all financed by the UFC.
Lorenzo pays for all this shit.
And you know,
they're,
they're testing blood or don't and they're doing it and they're doing it.
They have this like really intense chain of evidence where like the guy will
show up at your house,
take your blood.
Then it's like,
you know,
fucking suitcase,
he's got chained to his wrist.
Like it's one of those type of deals.
Like I travels with it to wherever the lab is.
Like it's in his,
his custody the entire time and they take the blood from your body,
he signs off on it and they bring it to the laboratory and then the laboratory
analyzes it and you're finding you're there,
there's going to,
they're going to find out.
A lot of guys are taking,
of course it's,
it's a really interesting one.
This,
it's such a large thing.
It's like people will try to talk about it in a three minute chunk on TV or
write one article about it,
but it's,
so,
it's such a large philosophical thing,
right?
We have to look back at what it means to strive and want to succeed and want to
Wayne and the desire to be great and all that.
I mean,
shit,
we can go and train at elevation,
which will increase your red blood cell count,
but you can't take EPL,
which we'll do the same thing,
you know?
Right.
And,
and for a lot of guys,
just like,
you know,
I want,
they want to be great and it's like at the low level,
so the mid levels guys are broke.
They were,
you know,
there,
maybe it's not as vital,
but at the top of it means five or $10 million in that chasing greatness has
always been there.
And this doctor's like,
I can help you chase grace greatness.
That's a naturally instinctively there to go,
well let's explore everything.
Right.
That's where like the ball called God came in.
Yeah,
right.
You know the Victor Conte guy who came along and came up with some different
strategies for avoiding tests.
Some drugs that hadn't been detected yet that they found were effective.
They sort of manipulated the,
yeah,
the components of some various performance enhancing drugs.
And that's where they got that stuff too.
They called the clear that they were giving allegedly to Barry bonds and a bunch
of different people.
And I had content on the podcast and he sort of explained the whole process
behind all that stuff.
He's is,
he's a fascinating cat because now he's kind of working hard to stop doping in
sports,
which is like really a weird position to take.
When that was your whole career was like juicing guys up.
I think I saw him on like dateline or something.
Yeah.
I mean I don't even recently,
I don't know how I feel about that.
It's weird.
It's very strange.
But I also don't know how I feel.
I mean these guys that were on the testosterone,
guys like Vito,
Vito is the poster boy,
right for Tesco.
Cause if you've seen the photos of him now,
like pre and post,
man,
it's really crazy.
Yeah.
Pull,
pull his photo of [inaudible] uh,
pre and post TRT because,
uh,
you know,
he's been saying,
I'm not on TRT anymore.
Now it's just tea and t.
And so then Chris Weidman posts,
hold on.
Is this,
what happens when you're placed TRT with TNT and he shows a picture of Trt v Two
r versus the wreath,
recent veto who's off testosterone and he has shrunken.
Yeah,
I mean he is really like Luke Rockhold just said that he has a chicken neck now.
I mean it's,
it's weird that's going to get to him.
You know what the easiest thing to do to get a a guy in the gym a big like now
that's a,
that's the wrong photos cause that's a photo of him before testosterone
replacement and after,
which you want to see is during and after Chris Weidman comments on Vitor
Belfort,
TRT and look for a photo.
I'll be like,
well I didn't really need it.
It's like then why were you taking it?
But yeah,
what do you,
how can you say that?
Yeah,
of course.
And you'll look at them.
But there's,
there's definitely like all kinds of stuff at play like that will dramatically
affect his confidence and his confidence.
How are you throwing SpringAhead kicks AI cause you got this level of
confidence,
I can do it.
That's not going to just affect how he looks and when it can do it will affect
the way he performs without question.
Shrink that down so we could see the full image.
Yeah.
Wow.
Look at this.
Look at his body like on the right hand side.
It looks like he's lost it at least 15 pounds.
Yeah,
and his neck and the swelling under his channel that's crazies is NAC has
shrunk.
Really traps.
Look at the difference in the left picture,
like how high his traps are and the right picture.
It's nuts.
I mean his body is shrinking,
but it looks so different.
It a,
it's a strange one too because you go into a gym with bodybuilders,
you want to get a guy just freaking out.
He's scar.
It looks smaller today.
Told those that shit.
Those guys,
especially guys,
been walking around in the world with the craziest body that you've ever seen
and now people online going,
he's got a chicken neck that's going to affect his choices from here.
It's a tough place to be.
Stay offline.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
Yeah.
He's definitely going to hear about all these things that people are saying
about them.
And it's interesting because people are saying like on the underground,
people are speculating like maybe this is going to make Vituro start using
again.
And if he does start using again and he's going to Piss hot,
you know?
And it's all also about like they're testing these guys who's testing them.
Where are they testing,
how they're being tested.
You know,
is it going to come down to the UFC,
has to show up at the gym every day while fighters training and have him peanut
cup every day.
I mean,
is that the point is what is the way to tell if a guy's taking anything?
Because you can,
the problem with urine tests especially,
cause like
g guys would joke around about it.
They would say that's not even a drug test.
It's an intelligence test.
You know that if you,
if you test positive when they're testing your urine,
you're a fucking idiot because the Ellis stuff like oral testosterone is out of
your system within 24 hours.
Uh,
human growth hormone is out of your system.
Within 10 hours.
Like he can't even test,
I don't think human growth hormone without using blood.
I don't even think you can test and urine.
So these guys are getting that we're getting popped.
They were just doing it completely wrong.
So now that there's this really stringent testing,
you've got to think,
well guys are cheating in the Olympics if they're cheating in the Olympics.
Like how are they getting away with it?
That's like some of the most stringent testing ever.
Their tea because they know when they're going to be tested
protocol.
Yeah.
A new thing.
It's like,
okay,
at three o'clock in the morning you set your alarm,
you take this one at three,
you know,
you drink this many liters of something before you do that.
Yeah,
they'll find a way.
I mean it's because the game is to try to win then try to win every little
scenario.
And the doctor who is trying to fix this thing,
he's got a game to try to,
when two people are motivated to try to do great things.
And this doctor's assignment in life,
your assignment in life while you have 20,
uh,
you know,
you'll make people laugh and call fights and do a million things.
But,
uh,
his,
his to beat drug tests.
This doctor,
this one doctor here,
his goal is to go out there.
I wake up tomorrow and fucking figure out how to win this contest.
I'm beating this test.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm really curious to see what's going to happen to these guys that were on
testosterone replacement and now they're off cause chill son is retired.
He's,
he's out of the business but [inaudible] still in it.
And Vito is one of the few guys from 1997 when he made his debut that is at the
elite level today in 2014 and is ready to fight for a title.
So it's,
it's really interesting,
really,
really interesting.
But hormones are a weird thing too.
I,
uh,
my thyroid burned out and I never thought of this until like this.
It's just how stupid.
Like I grew up by a nuclear power plant,
like in this town called [inaudible] Manitoba.
There's like a nuclear research plant there.
And when I was young,
my mom's thyroid went out.
And then when I was in my thirties,
mine just ended up dying as tumors in and stuff.
They fixed it up and you'd take a hormone to hormones,
stuff,
take your t three and t four and the other one is um,
uh,
thyroid,
Tsh,
thyroid stimulating hormone.
Those three things go out of whack when your thyroid is off,
you feel like shit,
like you can't function when your hormones go out of whack like that.
So imagine somebody,
I don't know what it would be like to have your testosterone at that level,
but it's got to throw you the fuck out of whack.
Yeah.
Well these guys that get off of it,
the thing is when you take testosterone,
you put this artificial testosterone in your body,
your body stops producing wrangler,
testosterone.
So if they had low test before,
it's even lower now because your body stops taking it.
You're injecting all the stuff in your system.
And you know,
he's only 37
years old.
This is a,
it's a weird thing to have like old man testosterone levels at 36 37 years old.
And then to have to face up fucking beast like Chris Weidman,
knowing that Vitor Belfort,
like when he fought,
um,
Michael Bisbing when he fought Luke Rockhold,
when he fought Dan Henderson,
all these guys,
he was on this artificial stuff and it was making him super confident he'd build
two strong needs,
was super explosive,
and now all that's gone and now he's still got tech
need.
Weidman's a on the phone.
He's like,
man,
you look at that guy,
you look at what,
he's a weird one too.
Like you don't even look at him and think he's just a modern amalgamation.
He's just genetically better than us.
He's more handsome than us.
He's funnier than us,
more confident than I,
he's genetically better than 97 99% of all men on earth.
And he learns fast and he's incredibly driven and he grew up wrestling and just
for the thing about wrestlers,
they just spend their whole time dominating other men.
That's all they're about growing up.
They dominate other men physically.
That's who that guy grew up with.
Dan.
He learns while it got the best coaches,
everyone believes in him like a guy like that.
Uh,
we called it,
he was going to beat Anderson Silva.
He was in our studio and we're talking to them.
And you talked to this guy in advance and he fucking believe without a shadow of
a doubt,
he was gonna beat him.
Even turned down.
Remember this,
he turned down his contract renewal and said,
no,
I'll beat him and then I'll sign my new contract.
I know I'll have to beat him twice.
Everything he said came true.
Everything that's animal.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
And he did it all.
Was knees all fucked up.
You know,
a lot of people don't know he did.
He couldn't even bring his heel up to his ass,
like his knees were so arthritic.
And then he went and got that Regena keen done in Germany.
And then after he had that done,
he still had to get his knee scoped but against Leono his knees were great and
now he's throwing kicks at him and shit and it's,
he's,
he's a different animal.
Yes.
He's an unusual dude.
He can take it too.
That's the other thing about why men like Leono unloaded on him in the fifth
round and it was still there kind of asking from one.
Yeah,
fourth and fifth round
when he was at fight,
now our can't a couple hours to kill to like what to the airport and he was
hanging out and Ram Dean started playing him in Ping Pong and ram was getting a
little slight better of him.
He fucking got dead serious.
I want a better paddle.
I'm not fucking around here.
Dead serious.
And he's like,
I don't like to lose.
He's pasted,
still have it fine.
It's still a good slug.
We're having a great time.
But he did not want to lose that game.
It was not in him to let this guy beat him in ping pong.
He's not a ping pong guy.
He just is not having it.
It just not having it.
There's a lot of guys like that.
I played Jake Ellenberger pool once and Ellenberger who a fucking stud.
He's not very good at pool and I've been playing pool a long time and he's
fucking,
every time I was winning,
he's like,
yeah,
sure.
Like you could see like he was handling it,
but he didn't like it.
Yeah,
but that's the quality that makes them great fighters,
that unwillingness to lose.
You
know,
the guy wants to fight you.
If you fuck a beat him at pinball,
you know like that.
That's that quality that makes them a great fighter.
Heating.
Losing,
yeah.
Yeah.
Once you're getting at this point where these guys are the top top guys,
they have to have all of it.
They have to have that quality.
They have to have that genetic Steph to have those coaches.
They have to have that mental game or else this just no way.
That's how good the whole level is now.
It's still getting better.
It's shocking.
Ellenberger had that fight with Rory and he's never been a ship talker and all
of a sudden he was talking to walk.
Oh,
all kinds of shit on Twitter and stuff,
and when he got in there,
it raised that pressure so high that you know,
it wasn't that I like,
I got to beat this guy who was,
I just can't lose bad to a guy.
I called a fruit stick on an inch and a half and the pressure of it.
That's why when people were so excited about Jon Jones and Daniel Cormier,
I'm like this kind of,
although it's great,
I love that people are into a fight.
I love like that.
There'll be about a million more people that normally watching a fight.
That's a love that,
that's awesome.
But for me personally,
I just want to see them fight.
They're going to fight whether they hate each other or not,
right.
They're going to go in there.
We're going to see 25 minutes or less of these two guys putting together their
lifetime of everything to fight.
Whether or not that guy hates that guy isn't really all that relevant to me.
Yeah.
Um,
I agree with you.
I was torn on that whole thing because I'm,
part of me loves the fact they're fucking with each other and yeah,
getting into each other's heads.
But I think that it does,
it's not a good representation of mixed martial arts to see two guys who are at
the elite level have a street fight.
Like
I hated that.
I loved when they were talking with no on.
Yeah.
Cause that was real.
That was funny.
When John Jones puts the microwave goes,
hey pussy,
that's amazing.
Him and then I would kill you.
I would tell you it was literally kill you.
Literally kill you,
John.
You take,
I would just let you kill me.
Yeah.
Come on data.
You can do better.
I'm a big car.
Me a guy,
man.
I know,
although John John is absolutely bright,
but when they fought each other on a stage,
I hated that stupid,
like two of the best athletes in the world and that's the worst fight I've ever
seen.
I don't want no part of that is bad.
People are going,
Oh,
you watch that show or you work in that business like in these idiots.
That's terrible.
But when they were talking about each other with a camera on,
that's real and there's so little real in the world,
you fucking win some some,
uh,
like hip hop award and you've got to thank God and you're fucking producer and
you're,
and you know,
I just feel so blessed and I want to thank the fans.
It's like fucking bullshit.
Let me see what you say when there's,
when there's not everybody.
Yeah.
That's the thing about that getting John and Daniel.
Well,
apparently that video was pulled.
Yeah,
it was more
apparently when they said,
guys,
you're a on the Internet.
I think again,
it's Melcher might have that,
hey guys,
uh,
you know,
you're being shot.
This could be around the world.
And,
and Jones,
his face just went like,
Holy Shit.
He,
like,
he realized,
you know,
that that was the,
that's the best part.
I don't know why that part doesn't get shared.
You know,
everybody's trying to put up an like John's,
his depiction of what happened when he first met Danielle.
I was just trying to make a new friend,
like what
they call them,
all the exact same story.
All the,
he said he did,
I did this,
this,
he did that.
This happened.
He was a dick and I got,
yeah,
I did this,
this,
this happened in the bar.
I was just fucking around.
But it's,
they tell the exact same story.
Well Dan,
well he wasn't even saying he was fucking around.
He was like,
I was just trying to form a new friendship.
Like fuck you where you're trying to let some duties and your division know that
you're the fucking king.
Yeah.
He ain't taking me down.
You know,
it was like trying to let them know is trying to fuck with his head and let the
gamesmanship begin.
Yeah.
And that,
that stuff is a definitely a law.
That's all interesting.
Cause that's all real too.
That's all having a real effect on the outcome of a fight.
All of that mental stuff.
Uh,
you know,
the guys at the weigh ins,
how they act.
I mean,
you've seen the science where they looked at the smiles and the wins.
No,
no science to this guy.
So check that out on the Internet.
These,
because these researchers,
these sociologists go and they looked at hundreds or thousands of UFC way ants
and they found that guys who smiled lost,
uh,
an extremely large percentage of them.
Real.
Yeah.
For Real,
for real.
And uh,
because that moment is a moment of the starting of the conflict between the two
males,
between the two alpha males.
It doesn't start when the cage car starts.
It starts when we're setting the tone of who's who in there.
And when the,
the smile is a giveaway of a circuit.
There's two kinds of small ones called the chess share smile.
And neither is the smile of I'm going to fucking kill you.
And that one doesn't count.
They look at the actual types of smiles.
It's real.
It's,
it's fascinating how one doesn't count.
No,
because it's a different expression there.
You know,
you can look at the slivers of expression and in um,
in psychology and what they mean and that one means something different.
Isn't that fascinating that the difference in like understanding facial
expressions like human beings kind of get when someone's creepy,
but like would a robot be able to figure that out?
You know,
study financially,
filing fighters are losing fighters,
but that's not always true.
John Dodson smiles every fight.
That's not a good example.
No,
just smiled before he fucks people up
to the math.
You look at the math and it's like whatever the numbers are,
he may,
there are exceptions,
you know,
they might lose whatever 68% of the time.
We're 63 that's higher than the 50 that you would think,
but that still means there's 32% of other guys who smile and kick ass.
It just shows that there is a sway,
you know,
in the statistical truth of that.
Hang.
That's funny.
Donald Cerrone and Anthony Pettis.
Actually I did a breakout send it to you of um,
of uh,
what the impression of Alpha male posturing the PR,
the effect that that has on fighting.
So you know,
like guys will stand there and they'll have a project,
a certain posture.
There was research done at the University of Harvard,
Harvard University about Alpha posture.
And what happens if you're interviewing me for a job and I have a certain
posture and they interviewed,
they talked to you after.
You'll score me much higher of your opinion of me also.
Yeah.
And that affects your,
when we go to fight
and I like Uriah Faber has that a lot and he projects a certain thing and that
will affect your performance.
But the mat,
this science actually shows that it affects his performance as well.
Cause there's certain postures that when you do them,
your testosterone rate raises a measurable amount and your cortisol drops a
measurable amount just by doing a certain physical posture.
Yeah,
it's real man
on therapy.
Why don't guys just postural day?
Some guys do that really work well.
It's,
there's a few of them in a big one.
So let me tell VTR.
Yeah,
exactly.
[inaudible] that shit all the way
traps.
It's a Harvard research anyways.
And uh,
they,
they did it to measure your pro,
your biological responses to your own physical posture.
But it also,
there's an interpretation of the other guy.
So I broke that down and then I took a piece of Donald's Serone standing there
looking over at Pedis and then I've superimposed with Serone set after,
and he said,
I looked across the cage at him and I looked at him,
I thought,
Dang,
I pissed him off.
And he's coming hard.
And it was the worst performance he's ever had.
And he talks over me.
Serone is fascinating cause thrown.
He's a regular guy who deals with fear and uses it appropriately.
And he talked about looking over and he literally said,
I saw that guy.
And he said,
after I knew I had to see us,
a psychiatrist,
like a sports psychologist or a psychologist because there's no way I should be
about to fight a guy.
And the things going through my mind is all man,
I pissed him off.
Never should happen.
But it was po in part the posture of of um,
pedis that projected that on them.
But that's an interesting,
yeah.
All each of these guys who wear red when a slight percentage larger all of a
sudden GSPS wearing red every time.
Cause guys are looking for one and 2% incremental raises and there are certain
guys anyways,
why is red make you win?
I don't know,
but I mean Mike Tyson always wore black.
Yeah.
Well Mike Tyson was my exercise.
Go to one pink.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That's okay.
It's probably something that you see in the wild when you see,
you know,
a certain color in nature and it has an effect on you each.
Yeah.
Each of these things might be one or 2% in the end.
If you can't fucking fight it doesn't matter.
Right.
You know,
like have the physical skills,
you have the technique and then you add on those other things.
Yeah.
I imagine you both guys at the top level have all that.
They're both have the best strength and conditioning on earth.
They both have the entire human history of fighting skills.
They both have all the mental training.
They have all that shit.
Shit,
man,
if I could get half a percentage of increase on my side in any way,
let's stack up two or three of those have percentages.
I wonder what the red thing is.
That's enough.
It's true in all sports,
uh,
sports teams that were red have won a slightly larger percentage of time than
any other color.
Real.
Yeah.
Wow.
I'm having,
this is the kind of shit that fascinates,
you know,
they also see the like red sports cars get pulled over more.
Yeah.
So it's something in nature.
It's something that we probably had to deal with as a threat.
Evolutionary
red is a threatening thing.
Like if you see an animal that's red,
like a snake,
it's red.
You assume that that's a snake that could poison you.
Yeah.
You know,
but like animals,
there's no red predators are there are,
there might've been certain thousands of years ago or some shit.
Yeah.
Send some wine.
Red is a winning color.
Yeah.
And saw that just start stacking up all these sites.
So now I've got years worth of fucking breakdowns I can do just from all these
things to reading and looking.
And it's like you start to combine them,
you know,
you've got the and the evolutionary hat and you got the job and you got red
winning,
you've got Alpha posture,
you put all that shit together.
What the fuck does that mean?
Right.
That's what I'm doing with my life.
That's interesting.
You know,
I also am fascinated and I want to bring this back to you.
I'm competing at such a lightweight,
I'm fascinating by the science of weight cutting and the negative aspects of
weight cutting.
This is an important part of MMA.
And uh,
one of the best examples in my opinion is Anthony Rumble Johnson.
Anthony Rumble Johnson who fought at one 74.
The majority of the first stint of his UFC career,
uh,
fought one fight at one 85 with Vito Belfort actually didn't even make the
weight,
was overweight,
got cuts from the UFC and then started fighting heavyweight fucked up.
Andrew Polaski as a heavyweight was destroying guys in the first round,
almost stopped him.
Really.
Probably they should have stopped that fight and then have fought in the UFC as
a light heavyweight.
Two fights in a row.
It's just been a murderer.
This is a world class dude.
Couldn't take full day.
Full Day was couldn't take them down and just got battered on the feet and then
destroyed little nog in the first round.
40 seconds of the first round just lit him up like a Christmas tree and it looks
like the scariest guy in the world at 205 pounds.
When his first career was 35 pounds lighter than that.
That's crazy.
I've never seen him in Ohio.
And I was sitting in the stands.
It was rap page versus Keith Jardeen and I was sitting in the stands and
there's,
he's pretty good the size of him.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
He is amazing.
What fight is that?
Staples Center?
It's probably a,
was that Phil Davis?
No,
it's Anthony.
John Noah.
Sam.
That might've been him when he fought at one 70 which is ridiculous.
Right.
Crazy.
But I saw him and there was these hot girls and like eight UFC fighters walked
over.
I'll,
hi,
great to see Ya.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
Those are the Ohio checks.
And Anthony walks over just to say hello.
I don't know how they might've fucking had a real job.
I Dunno.
I'm projected that on him cause they were pretty,
uh,
and he goes over it.
I turned to my buddy and I'm like,
that huge guy.
The fucking enormous guy looks a lot like Anthony Johnson and it was Anthony
Johnson now like 240 pounds it when he was a one 70.
Yeah.
So,
but yeah,
I mean the weight cutting thing,
I don't know how he did that.
He almost killed himself probably doing it.
And I mean if we're talking about measuring things that really work,
looking at the math of like,
is this better?
This,
okay,
great.
Your eight pounds heavier than the other guy that raises your,
let's say what you're,
if we're going to score your likelihood of winning a race,
is it 6% but the point of diminishing returns and what if it drops you 8%
because of the weight cut and stuff.
It's true for me.
I mean all of this was a learning experience so I can be a real analyst.
That's what I want it to do it.
So we'll cutting weight was an experience that I really needed to have and
understand it,
but it just,
wrestlers data,
they were good at restaurants were beaten everybody and they were bigger and
everyone else was like,
we gotta do this.
And I think you're right.
I,
I think you're absolutely right.
Well you got to see guys got away from it.
Eventually get away from that huge weight cut.
Zidan cut weight at all.
I mean,
I really wish they fought at no and everyone made an agreement to fight it.
What you way,
you know,
but everybody wants this advantage.
But the problem was when both guys are seeking and advantage and they both try
to achieve that advantage while you're actually wind up happening is it's okay.
Just got it.
Will you,
will you actually wind up happening is you have both guys that are fighting not
to the best extent of their abilities and so instead neither guy has an
advantage in both guys are compromised.
Yeah,
I agree.
and it's also dangerous when it comes to combat sports,
a difference,
true wrestling,
which is a combat sport,
but it's not a contact sport in terms of concussive blows where you're dealing
with striking.
There's a big difference almost all of the instances of a of brain damage and
death that occurred in boxing because boxing matches or a lighter weight fights,
not brain damaged.
Cumulative to heavyweight guys of course,
got that as well,
but in fights where guys like had bleeding on the brain and then were w and then
wound up dying,
almost all of them.
There was one recent one that was a heavyweight bound with Eric Perez,
fought a Russian guy and the guy had some swelling of the brain and his careers
probably over that was a prolonged beating,
unusual situation.
Whereas like boom,
boom,
[inaudible] and duck who cam that was a severe weight cut.
Um,
Gerald Mcclellan,
severe weight cut.
A lot of fighters who wound up having like horrible tragedies inside the ring.
It was because they had depleted themselves,
did dehydrated themselves and then they got it
beat up.
Yeah.
If there's gotta be a death and you know,
a high level MMA one day and,
and you'd have,
you would gas that if there was dehydration and the brain that would add to it
for sure.
Well the guy died in Brazil from cutting weight.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right,
right.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's true.
It was liver or kidney.
Can you fill?
Yeah.
Which almost happened to Daniel Cormier when he competed in the Olympics.
He had kidney failure and they pulled them out of the Olympic.
Yeah.
W and that big weight cut that guys do,
one of the tools they use is some hyperhydration where you use like a ton of
distilled water to flush all your sodium,
but it also has like a,
like a kidney trick where it's actually doing tricking your kidney to perform a
certain way.
It's really risky.
Yeah.
I think in the long run,
if everybody just said,
yeah,
let's just fight at arrest.
Uh,
Sam Stout and Kj noons had a fight up in Quebec city and they just like two days
out,
they're like,
oh,
how much weigh and man,
I'm weighing about one 71 what about you?
Like one 70 you want to just fight at one 70 and they just did it.
Yeah,
that's smart.
Yeah.
Smart.
I mean,
why torture yourself?
Especially at both doing it.
It just doesn't make
sense.
If you both walking around on one 85 and you're both cutting down to one 75 one
85,
you know,
you're probably both fight better.
The trick is that everything's that arms race.
We were talking about ever everything is somebody looking for an advantage to
win.
So we agreed to do it,
but then I'm lying and I actually cut 15 pounds and now I'm way bigger than you.
You know what I mean?
That it,
until you find a way to make it have to happen or make something that both guys
adhere to for some reason that's safe.
And this is,
this is the way they're going to do it.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
Like Bj Penn has a weird way of looking at things because a Bj,
although he dropped down to 145 pounds when he fought Frankie Edgar and his last
fight who would not ivy.
Yeah.
And you know,
and dolce tried to get them to ivy.
He wouldn't do it.
He feels like Ivs are cheating and Antal here.
Yeah,
the Ivy's cheating.
But,
but cutting,
weight's not cheating.
It's weird.
So like dehydrating yourself,
getting on a scale of one 45 and then drinking water's okay.
But yeah,
but putting it into you at different route is not okay.
Yeah.
There's something about like needles.
It's not natural.
Yes.
The whole idea.
I think most cats wouldn't agree.
He is a unique one now,
man.
But a lot of debate over at our office with a few friends and stuff about his
place in the world personally.
Like I think Bj Penn's one of the greats ever for a million reasons.
And other guy,
like certain people will say,
well,
his records has this or he never beat,
you know,
there's reasons to that.
People argue it.
But I think the biggest thing is pure talent.
And one thing I think people sort of forget.
You see a guy and you go to a guy's back and you trap his arm in there with the
hook.
That's a Bj Penn.
You take a guy on the fence and you turn your body sideways and you elbow him
when you're defending the single.
That's a Bj Penn.
Did we really see that at all before he fought Diego Sanchez?
You know when you,
when you got a guy in a triangle,
but he hides his arm over here and you pressure the straight armbar against your
face until he gives you the triangle.
That's a beachae pen.
There's all of these things that he did that you know,
and uh,
and he can,
I don't know.
It's a weird one.
I mean the very least,
he should be considered one of the most beloved fighters of all time.
Well,
he's a great fighter for sure.
And he's a two division champion.
He's without a doubt.
He's an all time great.
Um,
what I think about Bj is that Bj at his very best was outside of his comfort
zone.
He brought in Marinovich to do strength conditioning and he just got in this
unbelievable condition and when he fought Diego Sanchez,
he was probably at his best.
He was this a destroyer and he had incredible endurance.
I mean,
he fought and you know,
was he had the same like pace deep into the fight that he did at the beginning
of the fight.
And that's what plague Bj.
Bj is just extremely,
extremely talented,
extremely game,
very aggressive,
but didn't like to train hard,
didn't like to push himself,
didn't like to get outside.
I mean,
you know,
he'll dispute that he should go.
Of course he trained hard,
but did he train the way?
Train when news with a Marinovich is like,
he would talk about how he couldn't even hold his kid at night because he was so
tired.
But that's what it takes to be at that kind of level,
you know?
And he didn't like that.
Well,
I hadn't went where it started on this hand saying absolutely one of the greats
ever and the other side of the debate,
that's one of them.
And another one was I think has his choices,
his career choices,
misunderstanding messages that I think were given to him when fighting.
And I think the biggest one he fought,
Frankie had Garney lost and a big thing in his brain was,
see,
he doesn't cut weight.
He's the smaller man and he's faster.
I'm going to go back up to one 70 and I'll be the Frankie Edgar of one 70 you
know what I mean?
Frankie Edgar at one 55 him at one seventies theoretically,
his interpretation of the same approach.
I'm the smaller guy,
I'm the quicker guy enough with this other bullshit.
I'm just better,
I'm going to beat guys.
And then he fought guys like Rory and fucking Nick Diaz and these monsters.
There's no way this 145 pounders should be in there with Rory Mcdonald.
Just size and athletic.
He should have never been a one 45 or either,
I don't think.
I think you look like this is skinny,
emaciated version of Bj Penn when he was there.
I mean,
yeah,
you can make the weight if you just don't eat any food,
but then your body eats itself.
That's not smart either.
The and then him at one 70 was not like Frankie Edgar at one 55 Frankie Edgar,
one 55 is ripped.
He's in shape.
He's moving fast.
Bj had a role,
you know,
he looked Pudgy,
he looks soft.
He just didn't look like the same guy and he fought well.
He's a very good fighter,
but his physical is the the correct weight for him,
I will always think is 155 pounds.
Yeah.
Or if there was a one 50 maybe you don't have that existed.
Well,
I think 55 is fine.
You know,
when he fought Diego Sanchez,
if 55 is perfect,
I think the issue was that Bj needs,
he needed to be outside of his comfort zone.
He needed to be away from that camp and be,
you know,
with uh,
Matt Hume type guy who organizes entire camp,
brought in high level guys,
dictated his training and took him outside of his comfort zone.
Uh,
yeah,
but he also likes being in Hawaii.
He likes training in Hawaii.
You know,
there's a lot,
you know,
it's a lot there.
There uh,
there is that 10,000 hours theory,
right?
Uh,
there's a couple of,
you know,
uh,
guys who have done hard research onto this and one guy,
there's was a book called talent is overrated and it's buying that it doesn't
matter what you were born with.
If you outwork everybody,
you'll be the wing man.
And the other one is called the sports gene.
Right.
And it's the opposite.
It doesn't matter how fucking hard you work.
If you don't have that gene,
you can't do it.
Of course,
the truth is somewhere probably in the middle.
Well,
the truth is most certainly in the middle of the,
the issue is when you got a guy who's got excellent genetics and is working
hard,
then you get a Jon Jones.
You get a guy who has fantastic genetics and is super disciplined and focused
and trains very hard.
That's when you get true elite athletes like Josie,
you get
the elite of the elite when you have the best of both worlds.
When you got a guy who works really hard,
buddy,
I shit genetics,
he will never achieve greatness.
They just don't.
They,
I think you could get close to it even five years ago,
like we mentioned,
Florian Florian doesn't have no jeans.
He was just really smart and he worked really,
really hard and back and look how close he got close,
but not quite there because he just didn't have the genetics to do it.
But he sure as fuck got clothes for a nerdy little cat from Boston.
We didn't have terrible genetics.
I mean,
he's fast.
He had good kicks,
he had great Jujitsu.
You know,
it's just these elite of the elite,
the Bj Penn guys,
the guys who just,
they have that little something extra,
you know,
these,
these Liotta Machida's,
you know,
there's,
there's guys that just have,
they have everything.
They have genetics,
like Weidman,
genetics and hard work and focus and mental toughness.
Then breeding,
his family was good,
his family took care of him,
pointed,
taught him the things he needed to learn,
like he had all of it was dad was an NFL player,
you know,
so it's like those genetics are strong,
that's,
that's all a big thing.
And also I think growing up with brothers,
there's a lot of fighters that grow up with big brothers and they're used to
fighting in the house all the time.
And those guys wind up being motherfuckers man.
Like Matt Hughes Mad.
He was in his brother,
his brother was a mirror,
you know,
he's got a twin brother was also a savage and they beat the fuck out of each
other all the time.
And when did you have that sort of an environment?
Man,
you just use your extra tough.
You're extra strong.
Jon Jones,
he's too super athlete brothers and one of them is just so 43
and he's,
you see this guy's for real.
That's crazy.
That's not human.
That's certainly not.
If you came from outer space and you look down and you saw a pit bull and a
Chihuahua,
you wouldn't think those are the same animals we saw me and John John's big
brother.
You wouldn't think we're on the same thing.
Oh look,
there's two different kinds of stuff.
This one's smaller.
This one's three 40 Bridget,
the midget and Shaquille O'Neal.
Two completely different things.
Yeah,
but they're the same species.
Yeah.
There's,
there's genetics that are just undeniable and if you get a guy who's got those
fantastic genetics and he is in just engrossed in MMA,
I mean his body,
he's his body,
his mind,
his focus.
He lives at breathe,
eats and sleeps.
It gets up in the morning and thinks,
how do I get better?
That guy going to be better than you.
There's,
and also this physical power,
like especially when it comes to striking physical power when it comes to
striking is something you either born with or you're not.
Dominick Cruz is not born with it.
He breaks his hands all the time and his,
his,
his body's kind of fragile in a way.
He's got a mind for it.
Yes.
But will he be able to beat a guy like Borow?
Will he able to be able to beat the guys who have the genetics and have that
physical power as well?
There's these guys that have that knock out power.
That's Anthony rebel Johnson.
This is a god given
gift.
The world has given him a hand of cards and it is
excellent.
And then you put them with Henry Hoof to has a god given gift to take guys like
that and make them better.
And now we're now we're terrified.
Yeah,
it's fucking scary.
And Man,
there's so like the beauty of how he moves is like I trained with a guy,
Evan Boris,
whose um,
kickboxing coach who trained with Henry.
He was one of the guys carry in his bucket and learning from him and he's just
as passionate young guy up in Toronto.
And uh,
he tells me all,
it gives me insight into how Henry thinks and you know,
tries to show me stuff too.
Um,
you know,
in through Henry's eyes.
So you feel like you're learning,
you know,
one step down from this master.
Right.
And so his thing is with a guy like Anthony Johnson has said,
Henri Hooft is we'll say to him,
you know,
you got to be ready.
If you are ready,
you don't got to get ready.
That's the essential fundamental uh,
plan of Anthony Johnson.
The way he stands in the way he moves is at all times you're in a,
in a type of balance where you can deliver power,
cause you have power and we just need to keep you in a spot where you can
deliver it all the time.
So his take down defense revolves around that.
The way his foot works,
it revolves around that.
It's all built so that at any moment in time when you throw a punch,
you're in the state to be able to smash with it cause you're,
you have that gift.
Yeah.
And also when you see a guy like hoofed or anyone who teaches that classic Dutch
style of kickboxing,
it's such a tactical style and that style can be lost on someone who doesn't
understand what's going on.
Is it every movement has a purpose.
Every technique has a purpose.
Every technique chains into another technique.
The left hook leads to the right low kick and all these,
these techniques that go together like bread and butter,
they just,
they,
they're,
they're a part of a system,
you know.
And Duane Ludwig is the best at breaking down.
It says like he's got books.
Like he was over at my house the other day and he had all these books,
a detail,
all his techniques and how they intertwined together and what's,
he has steps and levels and he has a whole belt system based around these
techniques.
I mean,
he's spent countless hours analyzing and,
and,
and categorizing and putting all this stuff together.
And that's what sort of lost on a lot of people that you aluminate very well
with your breakdowns.
Thank you.
I appreciate that man.
I can't tell you.
I like how when,
when I wanted to do that,
I want it to do it for people like you and Bang Ludwig and fighters and people
in the Va.
I wanted them to like it in a what and a fucking means the world to me that
people like,
yeah.
Well you break down Jiu Jitsu until you broke down to Eddie's match with boiler.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
At Jiu Jitsu it's something I've trained a lot for a while.
And then I was in an environment where like,
I was literally in one day he'll hooked by like three guys who intended to
injure me.
Like it was a really bad environment and that own was
not a god of wrath,
but,
but it was like,
you know,
people and they were just guys in the gym,
but there was a little culture of God.
I'm like,
who's that fucking guy wears makeup is on TV,
thinks he's a fucking,
and they'd like came after me one and so I started trying to hurt you.
Yeah,
for sure.
Specifically heal hooks for the purpose of trying to me one.
Wow.
And later I heard I'd been,
you know,
heard from a number of people that that was a bit of the emo of a couple of,
anyways,
it's one of those things is like,
so I kind of got away from it for awhile and then um,
uh,
I started reading Eddie's books.
Actually I'm going to train at his place tomorrow night.
Hey,
yeah,
I trained last time I was in la,
I trained over there.
Fuck you take one class with Eddie Bravo and your whole understanding of
everything you think you know about Jujitsu,
the whole thing fucking falls apart.
Like it's,
it's so crazy that you sit there and it's like these are positions people use,
you know,
whatever.
We'll take the 10 or 15 of them and the guy goes in,
in between.
As you know,
obviously in between each of those,
there's an entire universe of,
of stuff to do in between the,
the positions that people already know,
US positions,
entire worlds,
you know.
Yeah.
That's what he has done a fantastic job of not just incorporating his own
techniques but incorporating other people's techniques into his style as well.
And just spent just like Dwayne,
countless hours analyzing positions and using them in the lab,
using them in the gym and using them with high level guys and figuring out like
a guy in his gym.
We'll come up with some new variation on a specific technique and then they'll
add it to the rotation and then the rectal drill it and then they'll,
so trying to find another answer.
When I was there just that one time,
and I had trained with Eddie,
we met in Toronto one time.
I took him up for a bunch of drinks and it was funny.
He's a really cool dude.
It's really cool to be,
have a buddy like that and I haven't been invited me to his gym and,
and stuff.
And,
uh,
he uh,
you know,
I I've got his books and uh,
you see,
okay I understand your mission control and make sure you got the leg lock.
You know the invisible collarb do,
do claw,
that kind of basic stuff.
You know,
they read a little bit about his basics.
You'll be a little bit about twister side control on the twist and then you
think you have an idea of what,
what the Eddie Bravo system is.
If you read that like I thought well in the world,
the guys who know about,
about MMA,
I think,
I know you take one class for them,
you don't know fucking anything.
Like there was something we did from some truck position and my first curiosity
was I need to know how this guy's brain thinks like why he thinks these,
how he comes up with this shit.
Cause there was something that felt a lot like a locked down position from
another angle upside down while holding a leg.
And I'm like,
okay well this is brain.
Well,
there's a lot of techniques you can reverse the positions of the bodies and just
say,
look,
well if I,
um,
on my back,
I get a guy with a triangle,
what happens if I'm not on my back but I'm on his back and I'm behind him and
then I can I,
can I just triangle there?
Yeah.
It's kind of the same thing.
The arm is there.
It's like,
um,
remember when Matt Hughes Choked Out Ricardo Almay?
Yeah.
That front choke,
they tee peed up with his head,
right?
Yeah.
And that's essentially an arm triangle,
but it's an arm triangle from a completely different position from a head to
head position.
So weird thing,
but it's the same position.
It's still choking off the neck on one side with the forearm and then with the
neck,
with your own neck and your own,
you know,
your own body pressing against it on the other side.
And this rest of that element of wrestling that where that was sort of a bull
dog kind of rest and kind of stuff.
And the Schultz headlock,
yeah,
yeah.
And the,
the weird like to either in the moment or have trained it either one is amazing
to figure out that the angle of elevating your hips so high drove that extra
thing,
like all those little elements made it beautiful.
But uh,
you have a black belt under Machado as well.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
You have to,
you have a gay black belt and a black belt in the system.
When I started training in [inaudible] 96.
Yeah.
Wow.
And so when you were training in 96 and guys would say,
oh,
there's some purple belt come through town,
everybody was blown away back then.
Right?
Like was that the level?
No,
no,
not [inaudible] 96 in [inaudible] 96.
Um,
well there was a few purple belts.
I started out at um,
um,
Carlson Gracie's.
Yeah,
I took one class at Hickson's.
See back then in [inaudible] 96 I didn't know that there was a difference
between Carlson Gracie and Hixon Gracie.
It was just Gracie Jujitsu.
And the only reason why I went from Carlson's to Hickson's at Hickson's was all
the way across town.
Carlson's like much closer to me.
It was like a 20 minute difference in the drive,
so I just started going to crossings and that was when Vito had just made his
debut against John Hess and they were actually calling them Victor Gracie and I
even accidentally referred to him as Victor Gracie during one of the things that
I did for the UFC in 1997 UFC 12 when I first started working for him baby.
That's fucking UFC 12 yeah.
Let's think about that man.
How long you been doing that?
I said that I've said this a few times.
I don't know if you probably don't realize it because when you're in stuff you
don't do,
often people that are driven don't often pause to look and be proud of what
they've done.
Maybe hopefully they do that,
but that you actually invented this,
the idea of commentating the sport,
which is very different than any other one and there's so many things that
people you think are just terms,
but they're terms that you said.
Do you know what I mean?
Things that you said that are common descriptive things.
They think they've always existed but they didn't exist before.
You said them in a lot of cases and that's really a wild thing.
The influence in how people observe this great sport and how big it influenced
that is,
well,
I definitely don't think about it but the,
the difference between this sport and a lot of other sports is that this sport,
the play by play guy is not the play by play guy.
The color guy is the guy who's the expert.
The martial arts expert essentially has to be the play by play guy as well
because he has to break down the subtle nuances of positions to people that are
watching at home.
Especially when it comes to the ground.
Right is a big issue with explaining Jujitsu to people that don't know Jujitsu
so they can enjoy it because if someone doesn't know like why is that guy
hurting?
Like what's what's,
what's going on there?
UFC One,
what happened there?
Exactly,
exactly.
There's,
especially when it comes to the ground game,
there's a bunch of positions that need to be illuminated.
So when,
when fights are happening,
I'm calling,
like I'm doing a play by play color job.
Like I'm also,
I'm giving like if you watch boxing,
the color guy will say,
you know,
they'll sort of like give you like an overall assessment of what's going on.
But Jim Lampley,
who's the play by play guy,
we'll explain like the shots that are landing and this and that that's going on.
And then the color guy will say,
well he needs to do that.
And he says,
and he says the how and the why.
Yes.
When I worked with Mauro,
I did it like a few dozen shows her moral and uh,
he uh,
explains to you that in his case he knows it.
So he will do the what and your job is the how and the why.
So when you do color with Mauro,
it is,
he does it old school,
which is why he's so natural at boxing.
No,
he transitioned in a boxing so naturally because he was not an actual play by
play guy.
But the odd thing,
and I'm a fucking full on moral fan and he had a huge influence in helping with
a lot of stuff.
But because if you're a play by play guy and you're not really obsessed,
if you're not deep into it,
he will start to get certain things where you are missing out on stuff.
So he might say,
you know,
uh,
he's on his back.
Why doesn't he put the hooks in?
Well,
if he wants to ride heavy on the hip,
he doesn't want that.
He wants to ride,
you know?
And so you start to sort of project what you think is next.
And that's why when you do color,
you're saying what is happening and what might happen.
Well,
there's a difference between moral doesn't train,
right?
He's not a black belt.
He doesn't,
yeah,
you,
you have to be,
I really believe that you have,
well,
I don't know if you have to be a black belt,
but you have to be a high level grappler to understand the nuances.
And you've,
I think you also should have some competition in your life,
some form of it where you understand the psychology behind competing,
rising into the occasion.
What's going on in that moment when you see a guy who's breaking,
you know you can,
you can learn a lot by watching.
But I think doing is really important and critical when it comes to breaking
down Jujitsu.
Um,
I've seen like I was watching a private the other day and someone that,
one of the guys and wasn't boss,
it was whoever was doing it with was I'm talking about a position and it was
saying that he couldn't choke this guy out because the arm is in on the gaiety.
Like he didn't know you guys didn't know it but that's hilarious.
It's crazy.
But what time was that?
It was like 93 like people knew in 93 that arming guillotines we're legit.
So like watching this,
this was clearly a guy who doesn't grow.
I think it was quadros guy.
It was a guy who doesn't grapple.
He doesn't understand and it's just going on his limited a book of knowledge,
but it's not based on,
it's not an extensive comprehensive like encyclopedia of,
of training and knowledge and of being obsessed with combat sports.
Uh,
Chavela I worked with two and fuck is that Guy Fun?
He's great.
Sell fucking fun.
Great.
Such a good dude.
And he's having so much fun.
Trust me.
I'd like it if more here's me talking about him and he thinks I'm being critical
and it will hurt him.
He's a fucking
very tender dude,
but I'm not,
I think Mara is a fucking genius.
I think he's killing boxing.
I think he's absolutely killing it.
He's amazing.
He's graded glory to,
yeah,
he was a good dude.
He is.
He really is.
He really does love fighting.
You know,
it's just what we're saying is just,
there's a reality of the difference between a play by play guy and the color
expert position.
Yeah.
And that's why he's such a good play by play guy and a,
and g,
you know,
he can call it,
and you're right,
the expert color is what's really going on.
If you,
you know,
if you were in this place,
what would it feel like?
You know,
I think that guy on the couch,
he's,
he doesn't know what it feels like.
Even just have a guide drive his shoulder under your face to Chinese sideways.
I don't know what that feels like.
It's fucking terrible.
And you've got to take care of that before you take over any other thing.
It's into certain positions like the von flue choke member when OSP fought,
um,
Nikita Karloff and he choked him out with that von flue choke.
And like a lot of people didn't even know what the fuck was going on.
But because I've been around for so long,
I've seen that show before when I remember when von flue started doing it on
people and then we started trying it out in the gym.
Really fucking oh,
that's so cool man.
It's weird like that being,
cause I'd like,
you know,
there's a big difference between then later.
Go on.
Well,
what's that?
Oh,
it's a von flue.
Choke and gone.
Oh yeah.
I remember when fire,
when von Flue was in the gym doing it.
That's fucking cool.
Well,
there was also a scene recently where someone was trying this old boss Rutan net
crank Bas Rutten has this like fireman's neck crank that he would do.
Yeah.
It's like from from like almost like he has a head on one side and the leg on
the other side,
he tries to connect the two of them together.
And boss used to tap guys with the bosses of fucking physical beast,
you know,
such a specimen,
but somebody tried it in a recent MMA fight and I remember in the middle of the
fight won't Blah Blah Blah.
I've seen this before.
What fucking choke.
It's like you never see that technique.
Then all of a sudden it's there.
It didn't work,
but it could,
you know,
when I was talking about pancreas boss was the other guy that it was like he's
walking in the ring and you looked at that and it like,
you didn't want to be in there with this.
Like,
Hey,
you see the boss and Pan Christ.
Yeah.
That would have been as terrifying as a human being.
Has Anybody had ever seen WWE?
The intensity.
That's what I thought about him and Evan Tanner and these guys were kind of
competing and then him and Evan Tanner came in there and it's fucking went
crazy.
Like they just put it on people.
Like they put a level of hurt on people.
That would have been terrifying had you never seen that before?
Well boss was the first like really high level striker in,
in MMA.
I feel like boss was the first guy.
If you watch his pancreas fights,
he was blasting guys with kicks.
Like you hadn't seen anybody kick that hard before.
It was more about Jujitsu before then.
Yeah,
I mean you had like Orlando Veit who's like a high level kickboxer was in the
early UFC,
but he was only like 165 pounds or something.
Like there was a small guy and he got manhandled by grapplers,
you know,
and he fought,
um,
was just fucking name the big judo black belt guy.
His name escapes me.
He wound up
fighting the same guy want to fighting Marco who os and Marco who was mounted
him and he tapped when macro who is planning to them
cap.
Yeah.
Well it was also because he thought that the position was lost like once a guy
got you into that position.
Right?
Yeah.
Him,
it probably was for him.
It probably wasn't,
I have an answer for that.
So it's like I can tap now,
I can tap after he hit me six times or I can tap if you hit me 20 times.
Right.
Gone unconscious.
Yeah.
There was all a lot of fuck shit back then to where people didn't know that you
could get out of positions and he thought that when you got into a position like
that was,
it was over,
you know,
must have been a wild time in the 90s to be trained in that.
And,
and uh,
because it was foreign to people.
Like if you told somebody you were trained in Jujitsu,
did they know what the hell you were talking about?
No,
they didn't know what it was.
Rem Co part do we think we might have called that one recently.
Remember we fought Orlando VA and got him inside control and blasted him with
elbows.
It was in that judo side control holding in head there and just boom elbowed
them unconscious.
Yeah.
That was fascinating.
Fascinating.
Is watching those guys like watching that sport evolve like that to like in the
beginnings were just people trying their style out and finding out that it
didn't work at all.
Like I remember there was that Ninja Guy Fought Pat Smith in step kicks,
which kind of John John's kind of brought back.
Like if you have enough reach and you know which kind of have all that other
stuff too,
you know these guys thought they were going to kick you once and take your knee.
Well there's a lot of people that say that,
you know,
hey man we file,
just kick somebody in the knee and take 'em out.
Like yeah,
okay.
Really you really think that it works that way cause you know the guy tries to
not have you.
Not only that,
he might see you winding up and like going towards his knee.
What was this motherfucker doing?
Like move his knee out of the way and then you're missing things.
Then you're all confused.
Your go to move didn't work.
Yeah.
And that's sort of the thing you've seen it definitely a guy goes in,
you know at the low level is kind of where I get to compete and call fights and
stuff.
Sometimes brand new guys sometimes go in there first thing in their mind.
This was going to knock a guy out the second that doesn't happen.
They just stayed,
didn't really think past that.
Now it's scary and horrifying place to be.
Well I remember Pat Smith fought recently in glory and one of the things that
really troubled me before his fight,
he said,
I'm a one round fighter.
You know,
like a,
I fight for one round,
you know,
this is,
I'm,
I'm there to win or lose.
But it's called going out in one round and then Mike,
you can't say that,
oh that guy's only job is to survive one round and he's got it.
Well,
not only that,
it's a crazy way of thinking.
This fight scheduled for three rounds.
If the guys exactly the skill level of you,
it's going to take some time,
man.
Like you can't,
I don't know why he decides to do that.
I mean,
he's one of those guys that like really likes to put on a show,
really likes to have an exciting fight.
And that's one of the things we were talking about earlier as these guys that
sort of sacrifice technical styles fighting in order to make things more
exciting.
But in the long run,
that's not good.
It's not good for,
it's not good.
It's not just not.
Yeah.
And it changes.
Things like that,
that idea that we're,
the whole thing is going on to try to figure out who's the best,
not to figure out who is close to the best,
but the most exciting or not to figure out who can,
if we all agree that you take down defense has gotta be the most important thing
for the next two years.
Who gets good at that and landing right hands.
Like,
it's not,
uh,
it's not a worldwide game to figure out who's the most exciting,
it's a figure out who's the baddest dude on the planet,
who's the best fighter in the world.
Yeah.
And the only way you find that his guys competing at their very best,
like using all of your,
like if guys played chess and they just said,
you know,
fuck all this strategy and shit,
I'm just going to get gangster at my rook,
like
no,
me.
That's really essentially the same sort of decision making.
It doesn't work that way.
It's all about using all of your talents,
your mental talents,
your emotional control,
your endurance,
all of those things.
Knowing when to push,
when to back off,
managing your energy during a fight.
That's a huge aspect of it as well.
Sure.
Managing your energy is absolutely critical.
Managing,
like when do you pour it on,
when do you back off?
Do you have that under control?
Is that taking care of itself out of stress or out of fear or out of danger or
because he pushed you,
I mean,
you talked about one round is Kevin Randleman was like in a fight you for three
minutes,
it was going to be the worst hell of three minutes that you've ever had in your
life,
but if you could get past it,
you've got a chance to beat.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those fast twitch muscle fiber guys that just,
they have a lot of fucking explosion in the beginning,
but they just slowly wear themselves out and then there's nothing left at the
end.
Tyron Woodley.
Yeah.
It's a great example of that.
He hates it when you talk about that.
I know.
Tough Shit.
Yeah,
it's,
it's important.
It's my job and I'm a fan of his and I think that he's too big.
Yeah.
I think he carries too much weight.
I mean,
the guy's got,
he's got a,
essentially he's running a race,
it's an endurance race and he's got this monster truck engine and he,
you know,
he's getting two miles to the gallon,
but for that first two miles,
she's a mother fucker.
You know what I mean?
Tyron is one of the best athletes in MMA.
His wrestling is physical strength is blitzes
blitz this matter what he did to,
what's his name,
the third day here on and even Carlos condit in the beginning.
Yeah.
You know,
conduit like until that lag went,
you were like,
how the fuck did he survive that blitz?
That was crazy.
Well,
his story,
his lead right hand is so fast.
He's so fast.
So explosive travels.
We talk about a Hendrickson,
how he can close distance this guy even more so.
Um,
but uh,
the what some I think athletic guys we'll try to do is make it not an endurance
sport.
They'll make it a sport of sprints and comms and sprints and comms and sprints
and cons.
And that would be the way to try to be that athlete.
We haven't seen anyone make that work.
But I think that's what guys are trying to do is you,
everything is a 32nd on in a 22nd recovery and fight that way and you know,
and a train that way and trained to recover that way.
But I don't,
I can't think of anybody we've seen sort of make that really work yet.
But I think that's how that level of athletes trying to do it.
Well it's also chill son.
Uh,
had a comment on MMA and about just the physical demands of the body.
He's like,
the reality is at 25 minutes is too long.
it's too long to fight.
He goes,
you can't fight at your best for 25 minutes.
So it all becomes about managing when you,
when you explode,
when you go after the guy and when you,
you know,
and for child to say that especially,
you mean you think about like his fight with Anderson Silva was a crazy
endurance test.
I mean he is when after Anderson,
that first fight for four and a half rounds,
just full clip took him down at,
we'll just push the pace constantly.
Most liking these on Epl,
they say we knew what it was later.
Yeah.
Know.
Um,
and still,
you know,
that's his thoughts is that it's just too long.
It's just too long.
There's,
except for a guy like mighty mouse.
Yeah.
Which is crazy.
Why is that 130 pounds,
you know,
225 pound guy does not have the same requirements when it comes to gravity and
there's nothing pulling on them.
Yeah.
That book I was telling you about that a,
I'm in the process of reading that um,
rise of Superman.
They talk about how some of these guys in the states,
a lot of the analysis is guys and skateboards.
The guy on the skateboard have jumped over the Great Wall of China and guys who
are flipping and,
and a downhill skiing and stuff that they start to believe that gravity applies
to them differently.
You know what I mean?
They start to take action as if gravity does not apply to them the same way.
I mean,
look at these guys jumps the fucking Great Wall of China on a skateboard.
Part of his belief when he's in the state to a try this is he has to suspend
reality.
Even fucking give that a go because any normal person looks at that and go,
there's no fucking way I can jump the Great Wall of China on a skateboard,
but this guy has to put himself into a state where that truth becomes not true.
Yeah,
fuck that.
I know,
right?
How does that work?
I don't know.
That's so crazy.
But he,
this guy,
you'll like the book a lot,
man.
That guy compare us a certain psychedelic trips.
He looks at how that also alters the brain chemistry and those times where
people are at one with something where they've actually,
they in some ways,
reality is just that thing we each have and yours is different now.
Yours is different in the moments where you bring these,
these brain chemistry,
this brain chemistry together in a state of flow.
And when you're in that state,
your reality is different.
And if your reality is different,
maybe the fuck you can jump.
Well,
kind of makes sense,
right?
Because isn't reality in a sense objective in that like how you feel about a
moment changes what that moment means to you.
So changes your reaction to that moment.
And I think that like those guys that do that park what park whore.
Yeah.
Those guys have to be like that.
Exactly right.
How do you think you can do that?
Those guys nuts,
man.
Yeah,
but they,
I mean you hesitate for one second.
You Die.
And that's the same with us flipping motorcycles.
Same with free climbing,
fucking mount,
whatever you,
you get it.
You create a state where if you do not believe for one moment you're dead.
Not Well Shit,
I lost a fight.
Or Ah man that cost me some money,
death,
death.
And these guys,
you know,
some of them will say,
I could spend months learning how to spend 20 minutes of yoga to get a taste of
that state for a second.
Or I can put myself on a rock face and have it for three hours,
two hours out of necessity.
And that's,
and that's what some fighters are doing.
That's what I mean.
All the top guys are operating in that state.
All of them.
Yeah.
Rock the rock face thing is really interesting,
isn't it?
When you see those fucking Alex Honnold crazy fuckers and the climb up these
things free climbing,
it's almost like a different animal.
Human animals walk around.
Sometimes we swim and stuff.
We don't do that.
No.
You know,
well he does,
but he's a human.
I mean,
it is.
it's essentially like putting your focus into something and taking that
something,
whatever it is to the highest level that's possible.
And the mind is a big part of it.
But he was talking about how when you're,
um,
when you're rock climbing,
I had him on the podcast,
he was talking about rock climbing,
that when you're,
you're doing it,
you're really pretty chill that it goes,
you,
you don't,
you don't really feel crazy unless something's really wrong.
He goes,
most of the time,
everything is really calm and really chill and you just sorta zen and you were
just,
this is what you're doing and you're just going through it and you're putting
the powder on your hands,
you're sticking your hands and cracks and you're just pulling yourself up.
He goes,
then you kind of get to the top for hours and doing shit that in his case,
do we shift from,
no one else does anger and stuff.
Why don't think they do that too much?
They try to just crawl.
I think the jumping up guys are fucking nuts,
but it's all levels of nuts.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
there was a piece that they did and one of those television shows where they
talked about Alex or this guy who was also a free climber who was like,
look,
it's a matter,
it's not a matter of if he's going to fall,
it's a matter of when he's going to fall and he's going to die when he does.
And you know,
this guy is kind of freaking the fuck out.
But then he talked to Alex about,
he like,
man,
maybe not,
I don't know if he's gonna fall.
This mother fucker might just keep doing that.
I mean,
he's a guy,
Alex Honnold that just,
that's what he does.
He lives in his van mean he's got a van with all these like drawers in it with,
this is where I put my toiletries.
This is where I put my underwear.
He's got like this,
he's this,
he has a bed in the back of it.
He sleeps in the bed and then he just climbs everywhere.
That the guys who get to that point of,
of human performance,
there's a level.
So where we discourage a obsessive compulsiveness,
you know,
we discouraged.
I'm sure there are damaging things about it,
but I mean you telling me that fucking guy,
an extremist version of that and yet it's been focused in a way that stretches
human performance.
Yeah.
I think they're obsessive compulsive is almost the only way to achieve
greatness.
I don't think there's any other way.
I don't think you can be like this really rural laxed like,
Hey,
easy come,
easy go.
You know,
no big deal.
No,
you have to be a fucking maniac.
It's all about how much focus you have on that goal,
how much intent you have on that action,
and if you're,
if you're not completely inset obsessed.
I've always said that greatness and madness are next door neighbors and they
borrow each other's sugar because you don't,
you don't get there without the other.
You have to be,
well,
I know when I was competing,
when I was at my best,
when I was a four time state champion and taekwondo and I won the US Open and a
bunch of the tournament's,
I was crazy.
That's all I did.
I would train in the middle of the night because I knew that no one else was
training.
I used to have the keys to the gym so as to go to the,
the doe jangs with the Koreans call.
I used to go there at two o'clock in the morning cause I had the keys and I
would train knowing that no one else was training.
And that was like,
I felt like I had an edge that way.
Cause I had,
I seen Mike Tyson talk about how we would run when everyone was asleep because
he think he felt like he,
his opponent was sleeping.
So that felt like deck gave him an edge.
So,
you know,
I would like that,
that kind of insanity.
Like I didn't have anything else going on in my life.
Everything else I was a loser in,
but I knew I was really good at taekwondo.
So that was what I,
I was,
I sucked at relationships.
I sucked at work,
I sucked at school,
I sucked at everything except taekwondo.
So that became my hundred percent of my focus.
And I know I was insane at that time.
I know it was some,
there was something wrong with me.
It was a terrible way to live your life and less.
That's your only goal.
The scary thing is let's say there's,
you know,
10,000 guys who are living that way at anything.
Comedy,
fuck,
fighting anything.
Only one of them's accident.
The,
we're going to get the 10,000 most obsessed and we're gonna find out who the
very best,
most obsessed or Jeanette.
You know what I mean?
The genetics and the obsession must come together in the perfect
storm because if your competing and you have the same amount of obsession as
some John Jones character,
fuck that guy's just too goddamn strong.
Too Big.
Like you see guys like get in there with John and then when John Locke's up with
them and then sends him flying through the air,
they realize,
oh,
there's another level.
Yes.
Who any almost took off to Sherri's arm.
That must've been fucking terrifying.
He's been in there with chocolate,
Dal and every great fighter at 205 pounds over the last 10 years of not losing
and training every day.
And this guy does this to him
or a part in the first round with some new move that he had been thinking about
doing.
John had just been thinking about it with John is so brilliant in his ability to
improvise in the heat of battle.
Like he saw the glow over was loading up,
so he decided to stand like right on top of him and then he would anticipate,
would feel him loading up and then avoid those shots and counter with elbows in
tight.
And he was fucking glove or up in the place where Glover thought that he was
going to dominate.
Yeah.
And they
went in there and the things that just,
he never even planned to use,
but a lifetime Greco Roman
playing in there.
Oh Shit,
I witness position.
Fuck it.
We're going to,
we're gonna win it here.
Then we'll that loose under hook.
That was what allowed him the,
you know,
Glover had this loose under hook.
So John just wrenched it just yet yanked on it with the overlook and tore his
shoulder up.
And it must have been mentally freaky too.
It's like,
what the hell am I in here with?
I thought I was just sitting here with a guy punches and kicks and chokes like
the rest of us.
Why does he do it's tearing off part of my body.
Well John is just,
he's always adding new wrinkles.
Like John is the first one of the first guys to really get good at that front
leg side kick to the thigh.
I mean he's real and he went to the downward angle too tall.
Yeah.
Well and also he's shooting down at your knee and John John Dropped v tour with
the front leg side kick to the body.
You know those,
those long legs.
Man,
if that's a huge advantage.
We only measure reach with uh,
with arms in MMA because we have this goofy system where all we do is copy
boxing because it's such a young sport.
We copied boxing when it comes to reach,
we copied box and when it comes to the 10 point must scoring system,
both things are woefully inadequate when it comes to MMA.
But a big one is the reach of kicks for sure.
Because John can kick you from a range where you can't even touch him and he's
hitting you with his best weapon.
I mean no and outside distance that he owns.
And your only way to get past that is to go through that.
Come on.
That's sparely fair.
And his legs are so much,
everybody kicks harder than the punch everybody does.
And John's an excellent kicker.
So he's out there kicking the shit out of you and you can't even touch him.
And what are you going to start doing?
You're going to start you on what was shot dead and trying to clear out of that
range.
You can't,
I mean you,
the way to handle it,
if it's humanly mentally possible as to pass it and get in there,
but he's training you the way you touch an element.
You never touch it again.
And he's doing that with his fucking kick and the front of it.
Also,
I think it's fascinating that John is now at this level where he's been the
champion for several years now and he's very confident and he's also used to
these championship contest.
He's used to the bright lights he's used to the big event.
It becomes a part of his every,
he understands that experience very intimately.
So when he gets in there championship fights with a guy like glow over,
this is the big show for Glover.
Holy Shit,
this is it.
And for John,
like here we go again and here we go again.
Is very different than all my God,
this is a,
here we go again as a much more comfortable place because every other time I've
been in this place,
I won.
People went crazy.
I made a bunch of money and I got even bigger.
Oh,
I'm in this place again.
And I love the,
his,
uh,
his attitude after the Gustafson fight.
Like his attitude was,
I've always been asking for a dog fight and I got what I asked for.
You know,
and this is a blessing and he's,
and you know,
it is [inaudible].
You don't know if you're just wrecking every guy.
Well,
what happens to one day where I can't wreck you for four routes when now he
knows,
he knows what he knows.
He can do wins.
Yeah.
Dug deep.
That was one of the most important aspects of that fight is that he faced a guy,
first of all,
with the same sort of physical advantages that he has.
I got with a really long reach,
a guy who was an excellent striker,
a better,
smoother,
more efficient striker than he is who took him down Confu added confusion to
that,
to the equation.
Did something unpredictable and then on top of that is still one.
Yeah.
You know,
and then man,
I was really looking forward to that rematch.
It was a bummer when Gustafson hurt his knee.
But what's interesting is Gustafson hurt his knee.
They canceled the fight,
but now John hurt his knee.
But the Cormier fight is still on.
Yeah.
Well of it's run by a commerce.
I mean we have to wear in the business then.
I don't think the UFC,
what's the bigger fight though?
And you want it?
I'm more,
they're both pretty fucking both.
Pretty Fun.
It's pretty fucking good.
I think they're both tens.
Yeah.
Call me is so fascinating because we haven't seen it.
You know,
you see all you gotta do is flash up what he did to Dan Henderson,
throwing them up in there.
No one's ever done that to Dan Henderson.
He got and then you got all this heat that gets regular people excited.
But I mean what happens when a guy got that close Gustafson's confident he's,
he believes he's going to win this time.
He thinks he's learned some things like that's real.
You gotta do 'em both.
But I think he got to do the one that the people are most excited about,
which is the one where guys fight on a stage and then say they're going to kill
each other off time.
I think that's how it's more exciting.
It's like almost like when when Daniel Cormier grabbed John's neck and threw him
back,
he ensured that that fight was going to take place.
You know,
cause you know,
if Gustafson got knee surgery and John can't fight until January,
I mean we should go back to that.
Yeah.
In theory that should be the fight.
But everyone is so hyped up on the,
the coronary fight now.
But you know,
core may went into that fight,
like you agreed to that fight with a preexisting injury that he was pretty vocal
about it.
He has a partially torn ACL,
he's got an MCL strain or a tear in his MCL and he's,
you know,
now he has more of an opportunity to rehab it.
But when you have a partially torn ligament,
like especially in ACL ligament,
I dunno how much rehab you can do,
you know,
you either get the surgery or you live with it and that and whenever 75% state
it's,
and until you get the surgery,
I think it's a 50% so I think it's 50% torn.
All three of those guys.
That's knee issues.
I don't know if that's how two oh five thing.
It's a height thing.
It's a wrestling,
wrestling thing.
Wrestling and Jujitsu and,
well look,
I mean even kickboxing you're going to have knee issues,
but just the nice sucks.
It's a shitty design.
Shoulders sucks.
Well it's not that they suck.
It's the human body's not designed for MMA and not for that.
Especially not for Jujitsu.
I mean Jiu Jitsu is all about testing the boundaries of your joints.
He Alma planet guys over that.
It's shit.
It's wants to do that office to do that and there was a few guys like Keeney
Cornelia said,
I've just unbelievably ridiculous flexibility of their joints.
Like what is that from?
Is that from straining them all the time and pushing and pushing to the limit?
Yeah,
like in theory,
how do you stretch your neck?
Add those circles if you're,
you know,
or you stretch your lip or whatever.
Can we do with with ligaments
and software
tissue?
I guess they can.
We'll look at Hoya.
Gracie,
when he fought Eddie,
I'm going to tell you something.
I've been in that position before.
You know that is a brew.
When Eddie had that leg and he was twisting the Oilers leg like that,
that that's called a vaporizer is an unbelievably painful position.
I do not know how heuler didn't tap.
Yeah,
mental that that way.
I don't think that was some biological,
it's thing he's authored.
I think that was a guy just saying,
my life depends on,
you know,
his reputation,
who he is as a person,
his business,
all of those things dependent so heavily on him not giving into pain.
And I think he was capable of,
of doing that.
But he has a history of having incredibly flexible joints.
Like when he fought Sakuraba Sakuraba had him in that deep,
deep Kamora and the referee stopped the fight and he was furious.
He was like,
I'm fine.
Like he had his arm like cranked up behind his back,
you know,
first of all,
it's crazy when you think of the fact that Heuler Gracie fought Sakuraba and
Sakuraba fought Vitor Belfort and Vandelay Silva.
Like thinking about the difference in size between those guys.
I mean incredible being just unbelievable.
Uh,
he won the fucking Abu Dhabi's at one 45.
Yeah.
You know,
and fuck does giants.
Yeah.
How the fuck,
that was another time.
And,
I mean I love hearing the stories from guys that were around in the early days
when they're like,
yeah,
well you know we drove nine hours cause they said we were going to have uh,
an MMA fight and we got there and they saw all your opponent's side here you've
got this guy.
And he's like,
I wait one 40,
he's won 75.
They're like close enough.
Fight them.
You know,
that's how it was.
And who is that guy?
Where does he train?
I Dunno,
he just got out of prison or do you want the bouncer?
I mean,
and that's who you fought.
And these lunatics on the front end of the sport.
We're driving around for $100 spending 300 to get there.
Not Knowing.
I mean,
you didn't know if the guy knew the death touch or something.
He didn't know if there was,
you didn't know if there was some other things he could do
back then.
What if they knew it?
There's people still teaching that stupid shit and there's people out there,
they're also still teaching.
You know what we do works on the streets.
The streets are very different when you do as a sport.
That nonsense drives me fucking bananas.
I was on the opiate,
Anthony shown these to have this guy they'd like to,
their security is fucking fake karate guy and he would always talk about like a
street techniques.
What we're doing is all about street street defense and I go live meet.
Let me tell you something dude.
What works on trained killers is the best shit.
All this nonsense about like street techniques.
Like you're going to do that and do this and that's going to work better and
you're going to fucking death touched somebody in their solar plexus and go
after their pressure points.
Bullshit.
It's all nonsense.
You know,
and if you try to bite somebody,
let me tell you something.
If a guy gets on top of you and mounts you and you just bid him,
he's going to fucking kill you apps.
He's going to take your eyes out,
he's going to kill you.
He's going to break your jaw.
He's going to tear your arms out of their sockets and leave you a cripple.
And that God could do that for sure.
And if you get all this street shit in your head,
dangerous.
But if you get your train a crab,
my guy or whatever,
and you're up against some dumb ass eight will be valuable.
Sure.
What if you're up against
a trained fighter,
you're going to be a lot of trouble.
Well,
you should always prepare for a trained fighter.
And that's the difference between like the street systems versus real MMA,
like real MMA.
So stuff that works.
It's,
it's the best application the human body has when it comes to using your body in
a combat sports scenario.
It's the best.
That's the reason why you don't see Kung Fu in MMA.
I mean,
Roy Nelson Jokingly Calls Himself a Kung foo fighter and I know he has actually
done some Kung Fu training,
but the reality is Roy's throwing a fucking heavy overhand right.
He's got a black belt in Jujitsu to back it up.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
uh,
if,
I mean,
hey,
if,
if for whatever reason you like wearing a kung fu outfit and doing all this
stuff,
it makes you feel good fucking gold train it for sure.
Yeah,
but don't try to tell professional athletes and people who would analyze it all
day every day that this thing is going to be the thing.
Because why the fuck isn't George Saint Pierre using it?
George,
he told me one time that he just,
he said,
damn shirts.
It happens to you a lot too,
that people come up to him and say,
Hey George,
you know,
a,
you do really good man.
Hey,
we should try it together.
I Have Kung Fu studio down the street and they would literally,
I can teach you some shit.
And really literally believe now when they're talking to the greatest fighter in
the world at the time that they got some secret shit back on the unsafe Denise
Street and Quebec and Montreal that he could teach short St Vr.
This got really fucking believes that
they really believed the got some death touch.
They're going to pull out and George is going to go,
this is going to change my whole career.
Thank you for teaching me death touch that she has got to happen to you too,
right?
Oh yeah.
Well there's always some guy that says that he has some new thing that no one's
ever seen before.
He has his master can't be defeated or there's a bunch of knuckleheads out
there,
man.
It was about,
but George is an amazingly patient guy.
I've seen George deal with a lot of fucking people.
He's a then one of the nicest guys ever reached like a super high level of any
combat sport and really open minded like he'll listen to it.
Yeah,
I've seen him exchange techniques with people.
I saw him turning side kick with many of his Nilo.
Yeah,
he's using his knee low and without questioning,
train fucking taekwondo for 10 years competing all over.
That's how you do this.
A turning sidekick and he got any understood that?
Yeah.
Well it was out.
That was a weird moment because John Danaher was a friend of mine was talking
and we were out to eat after a fight.
Me,
him and Eddie.
And uh,
he said,
do you guys know any good taekwondo guys?
George wants to work on the mechanics of a spinning back kick.
And I said,
this is going to sound so stupid,
but I have to say it like I have a great spinning back kick like my spinning
back kick.
I really know how to do it better than anybody.
And you know,
you say that and people go get the fuck out of here.
Lifetime martial arts expert.
But you still okay because I'm a comedian and a fucking a commentator.
I'm not a fighter.
You know,
I mean that those days are long gone.
But that doesn't mean that a lifetime mastery of a technique isn't.
And that's true,
but so many people have ridiculous egos.
There's so many,
and I'm not going to name any names,
but I know a lot of guys that are involved in the same sort of thing that I'm
involved in.
They'll tell you that they're great and then you train with and you're like,
Oh fucking Christ,
I'm wasting my time.
So I had this moment where I was like,
tell George if he wants to train on.
And then Eddie told him like,
dude,
seriously,
you gotta see this Guy Kick?
And I'm like,
this sounds so stupid.
Like no one's gonna believe me.
And so then George showed up.
So I was,
I was hoping,
you know,
when George showed up like that,
he wasn't like,
go,
okay,
come on,
show me,
you know,
this is stupid.
Why am I wasting my time?
Well,
once I kicked the bag once and then he went,
oh shit,
like this is real.
And then you could see like,
like he got this,
like,
I'm actually going to get something out of this as opposed to like,
I'm just being nice to Joe because we're friends and I'm going to go humor him.
And you know,
he's gonna throw some pussy ass kicks,
right when he saw me kick a bag,
you know when you hit,
he kick a 200 pound bag and it goes fine.
And then it puts it in your head.
You Go,
oh,
I get it.
I get it now.
But it was,
his open mindedness was so impressive because I wouldn't have listened to me.
I would've been like,
bitch,
get the fuck outta here.
Like George is going to give you advice on your job.
Exactly what I maybe exactly,
you know,
if you have an open mind.
But uh,
I uh,
when I did that TV show where I was learning to fight,
I trained with George and we do sat on the show and I was terrible.
Like,
I mean I literally was trying to take,
to play doing taekwondo growing up and add kind of boxing my head.
Like I'm a fucking horrible and I had never wrestled Dave my life,
I was doing Jiu Jitsu like 10 times a week for whatever number of months.
Never.
And that will forever people will just put that on goal.
Fuck this guy's terrible.
And it is bad.
But I mean,
what the fuck you're doing a TV show by taking some guy who wears eye makeup and
trying to teach him to fight.
He happened to be there.
And with Georgia course,
he's terrible.
You know,
you know the beautiful
thing about martial arts or any difficult endeavor is that you start off,
everybody starts off,
they sabal.
If you don't have those techniques,
you don't know what you're doing,
you're not going to be good.
And then as you train,
you get better.
And when you get better,
it's like you go down a path and then you can stop and pause and look back in
the look.
When I started,
I started way back then and now here I am getting better and then you turn
around and go,
but look how far I got to go.
And that's exciting.
Yeah,
well that's the beautiful thing about martial arts is that there are so many
levels and when we're seeing in mixed martial arts is like the Jujitsu is still
at a fairly low level.
I think that you do to still like purple belt level at even like a high level.
It's not like Marcello Garcia,
like high level black belt.
The striking is still at a fairly low level.
We're not singing Ernesto hoost yet.
We're not seeing these like ridiculously technical,
absolutely perfect executions of striking technique.
We're getting closer,
we're getting closer with the Jujitsu.
We're getting closer with a striking,
but there's room to grow.
And that's one of the reasons why we're seeing new techniques now.
Like how many people are throwing wheel kicks now?
There was no wheel kicks up until Terry Adams fought Ed Barboza.
But you know,
there was a,
um,
uh,
like this has been,
has this been seen before?
Like when Tony Hawk did the four things,
right?
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Within a year,
10 guys could do and get it into training the quad and,
and figure skating.
Nobody could do it.
Now if I can college level figure skaters through the quad because a four minute
mile.
Yeah,
yeah.
When it happens once,
suddenly it's now real humans do this just because,
I mean,
just cause that guy did it,
not every guy thinks he can do it,
but some guys think that,
yeah,
it's an amazing thing to watch the actual growth.
I love it.
I'm so fascinated too,
man.
Me Too.
It's such a cool aspect of of martial arts to be there.
While this is all going down and see this,
this thing evolving and getting better front kicks to the face now and same
thing.
All of a sudden there was the quad in figure skating.
They're all due at front.
The front kicks in play for almost every good striker.
Now that's in play for,
we've also seen a lot of that sideways karate stance like Ryan Jimmo does and
Gunnar Nelson does and Leotta does that sideways karate stance is a totally
different thing.
Some guys you see are using it.
They grew up,
you use again and when they are and for a right handed guy it's whenever they
switch the stance and the right foot is in the front is when you're going to see
it.
You know what I mean?
Like it's,
it's suddenly like not as camouflaged anymore.
Not only are guys using it,
but it's like,
oh shit,
he's in that stance.
I better watch it.
Do you see a lot of front leg kicks off the the dominant stance leg dominant
leg?
Yeah.
There's not a lot of guys.
She developed that powerful front leg left sidekick.
They develop it off the right leg.
Do you remember when Chris Clements did a,
did a spinning thing on that?
I brought that down.
Yeah.
The big question people had was how did he know to do that?
And when you look at it,
you see wonder why,
and he turned sideways and Chris and Mia and I froze and said,
look at,
here they are.
This is a mock.
Chris grew up doing taekwondo.
Christmas about tradition Marshall as well,
so he knows when this right leg comes forward and the stance is distributed this
way.
Neither a sidekick is coming,
oral hook kick is coming or around [inaudible] round kick in and it was,
the hip was flared enough.
Then he split.
It was probably you didn't,
it was the round kick wasn't as in play because of the position of how far his
shoulder or hip was.
So then we freeze it said that's what he knows what he knows from a lifetime of
that,
that both of those were in play.
Now what?
Let's watch it,
throws the sidekick and got freeze.
Now Chris had his mind would know if this still happens,
the next option,
since he's just giving me a sidekick,
his point is hoping to drop my hands and Hook,
kick me in the hat.
When he saw that happen,
there was a little flair of the hip and his brain goes,
oh yeah,
that's coming.
And then he timed it on the hook kick.
But it was his ability to kind of see the future,
you know what I mean?
Like he could he and we predict the future all the time.
Yeah.
When you go to open a door handle,
the reason if it was really hot or if it was spongy that you'd be surprised is
because your brain was predicting what a door handle would feel like.
Yeah.
And that's what you were talking about earlier when it comes to pattern
recognition that that's a big thing for pattern recognition.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
And it's definitely
what guys are playing with.
Like,
um,
how do you know Adam?
A zoo?
Check he trans Sarah Kaufman,
but he's also kind of a secret weapon for Greg Jackson.
He's up in Victoria,
BC and he sends guys up there to do certain things with very talented and we
were talking about after Sarah's fight coffins fight her last one in Quebec
city.
She was throwing a lot of off tempo things which he taught her cause she's a
dancer.
All right?
So he can work footwork off time and risk different rhythms with her.
But uh,
uh,
he was also talking about pattern recognition and how him and Greg Jackson,
that's one of the things there are on heavy is training you to expect certain
patterns,
chunking those patterns that your brain anticipates and then giving you a
surprise.
And that's on the front end of some of their thinking right now.
So far.
Slack.
Yeah man,
I need,
and then what's so cool is when you have that many great minds doing it,
now you've got one of these guys thinking that,
but you've got Duane over here.
Let's go over there and there's all these different guys in there.
And the group.
This is in Wisconsin and he's looking at it and trying to break it down and put
them against each other and the lessons that we learned there.
Everybody's going to go back in their labs and prepare for the next one.
Yeah,
amazing stuff,
dude.
We're out of time.
This is a lot of fun.
Thank you,
Robin.
Thank you for having me.
It's a real thrill and,
and thanks for digging my stuff.
I appreciate that you're doing it.
I really appreciate you doing the podcast too and we've got to do this again
man.
I love,
how often are you in la?
My wife's work in here right now,
so I'm visiting a little bit.
She's in theater,
so a,
not all that often,
a couple times a year,
but I love to,
I'll come back,
I'll bring some beer.
We'll do it again.
We'll do it again for sure.
Follow him.
Robin Black,
m m a on Twitter and a where can people see the videos?
Network guys at [inaudible] dot com we've got some stuff,
but fight network has a 24 hour television station.
It's in Canada and us and now in New York,
New Jersey,
Connecticut,
Texas as on Roku.
And you can call up any cable provider and say,
I want find networking.
And it's,
it's a 24 hour fight channel
and that's where I'm at.
Beautiful.
All right,
and thanks to our sponsor,
thanks to legal zoom,
go to legal zoom.com entering the Codeword Rogan in the referral box at checkout
to save yourself some cash.
Thanks.
Also to nature box,
go to naturebox.com/rogan that's naturebox.com/rogan and get 50% off your months
first box.
Thanks also to onnit.com go to o,
n n I.
T use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off any end.
All supplements.
All right,
we will be back in about 20 minutes with scrupulous pip.
Much love.
See Ya.
Take care of big cast and wow.
Okay.